I think it's possible that physics has exploits and we should be trying to find them arranging
some kind of a crazy quantum mechanical system that somehow gives you buffer overflow, somehow
gives you a rounding error in the floating point.
Synthetic intelligences are kind of like the next stage of development.
And I don't know where it leads to, like at some point, I suspect the universe is some
kind of a puzzle.
These synthetic A.I.s will uncover that puzzle and solve it.
The following is a conversation with Andreak Apathy, previously the director of AI at Tesla.
And before that, at OpenAI and Stanford, he is one of the greatest scientists, engineers
and educators in the history of artificial intelligence.
This is the Lex Friedman podcast to support it, please check out our sponsors and now
dear friends, here's Andreak Apathy.
What is a neural network and what does it seem to do such a surprisingly good job of learning?
What is a neural network?
It's a mathematical abstraction of the brain, I would say, that's how it was originally
developed.
At the end of the day, it's a mathematical expression and it's a fairly simple mathematical expression
when you get down to it.
It's basically a sequence of matrix multiplies, which are really dot products mathematically
and some nonlinearity is thrown in.
And so it's a very simple mathematical expression and it's got knobs in it.
Many knobs.
And these knobs are loosely related to basically the synapses in your brain.
They're trainable.
They're modifiable.
And so the idea is we need to find the setting of the knobs that makes the neural net do
whatever you want it to do, like classify images and so on.
And so there's not too much mystery, I was saying it, like you might think that basically
don't want to end out with too much meaning with respect to the brain and how it works.
It's really just a complicated mathematical expression with knobs and those knobs need
a proper setting for it to do something desirable.
Yeah, but poetry is just the collection of letters with spaces, but it can make us feel
a certain way.
In that same way, when you get a large number of knobs together, whether it's inside
the brain or inside a computer, they seem to, they seem to surprise us with their power.
Yeah, I think that's fair.
So basically I'm underselling it by a lot because you definitely do get very surprising emergent
behaviors out of these neural nets when they're large enough and trained on complicated
enough problems.
Like say, for example, the next word prediction in a massive data set from the internet.
And then these neural nets take on a pretty surprising magical properties.
Yeah, I think it's kind of interesting how much you can get out of even very simple mathematical
formalism.
When your brain right now is talking, is it doing next word prediction or is it doing something
more interesting?
Well, it's definitely some kind of a generative model that's a GPT-like and prompted by
you.
Yeah.
So you're giving me a prompt and I'm kind of like responding to it in a generative way.
And by yourself, perhaps a little bit like are you adding extra prompts from your own
memory inside your head?
Or no?
Well, definitely feels like you're referencing some kind of a declarative structure of like
memory and so on.
And then you're putting that together with your prompt and giving away some answers.
How much of what you just said has been said by you before?
Nothing, basically, right?
No, but if you actually look at all the words you've ever said in your life and you do
a search, you'll probably said a lot of the same words in the same order before.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm using phrases that are common, et cetera, but I'm remixing it into a pretty
sort of unique sentence at the end of the day.
But you're right.
Definitely.
There's like a ton of remixing.
Why?
You didn't.
It's like Magnus Carlson said, I'm rated 2,900, whatever, which is pretty decent.
I think you're talking very, you're not giving enough credit to neural nets here.
Why do they seem to?
What's your best intuition about this emergent behavior?
I mean, it's kind of interesting because I'm simultaneously underselling them.
But I also feel like there's an element to which I'm over like it's actually kind of incredible
that you can get so much emergent magical behavior out of them despite them being so simple
mathematically.
So I think those are kind of like two surprising statements that kind of just juxtapose together.
And I think basically what it is is we are actually fairly good at optimizing these neural
nets and when you give them a hard enough problem, they are forced to learn very interesting
solutions in the optimization.
And those solution basically have these emergent properties that are very interesting.
There's wisdom and knowledge in the knobs.
And so this representation that's in the knobs doesn't make sense to you intuitively
that a large number of knobs can hold a representation that captures some deep wisdom
about the data it has looked at.
It's a lot of knobs.
It's a lot of knobs and somehow speaking concretely, one of the neural nets that people
are very excited about right now are our GPs which are basically just next word prediction
networks.
So you consume a sequence of words from the internet and you try to predict the next word.
And once you train these on a large enough data set, you can basically prompt these neural
nets in arbitrary ways and you can ask them to solve problems and they will.
So you can just tell them, you can make it look like you're trying to solve some kind
of mathematical problem and they will continue what they think is the solution based on what
they've seen on the internet.
And very often those solutions look very remarkably consistent, look correct potentially.
Do you still think about the brain side of it?
So as neural nets is an abstraction or mathematical abstraction of the brain, you still draw wisdom
from the biological neural networks or even the bigger question.
So you're a big fan of biology and biological computation.
What impressive thing is biology doing to you that computers are not yet, that gap?
I would say I'm definitely on a much more hesitant with the analogies to the brain than
I think you would see potentially in the field.
And I kind of feel like certainly the way neural networks started is everything stemmed
from inspiration by the brain.
But at the end of the day, artifacts that you get after training, they are arrived at
by a very different optimization process than the optimization process that gave rise
to the brain.
And so I think I kind of think of it as a very complicated alien artifact.
It's something different.
I'm sorry, the neural nets that were training.
They are complicated alien artifact.
I do not make analogies to the brain because I think the optimization process that gave
rise to it is very different from the brain.
So there was no multi-agent self-play kind of set up and evolution.
It was an optimization that is basically a, what amounts to a compression objective on
a massive amount of data.
Okay.
So artificial neural networks are doing compression and biological neural networks are now
to survive.
And they're not really doing any, they're an agent in a multi-agent self-play system that's
been running for a very, very long time.
That said, evolution has found that it is very useful to predict and have a predictive
model in the brain.
And so I think our brain utilizes something that looks like that as a part of it.
But it has a lot more, you know, gadgets and gizmos and value functions and ancient
nuclei that are all trying to like make a survivor and reproduce and everything else.
And the whole thing through embryogenesis is built from a single cell.
I mean, it's just, the code is inside the DNA and it just builds it up like the entire
organism with the sounds.
I'm crazy.
And legs.
Yes.
And like, it does it pretty well, it should not be possible.
So there's some learning going on, there's some, there's some kind of computation going through
that building process.
I mean, I don't know where, if you were just to look at the entirety of history of life
on Earth, where do you think is the most interesting invention?
Is it the origin of life itself?
Is it just jumping to eukaryotes?
Is it mammals?
Is it humans themselves, homo sapiens?
Are the origin of intelligence or highly complex intelligence or is it all just a continuation
of the same kind of process?
Certainly, I would say it's an extremely remarkable story that I'm only like briefly learning
about recently, all the way from, actually, like, you almost have to start at the formation
of Earth and all of its conditions in the entire solar system and how everything is arranged
with Jupiter and Moon and the habitable zone and everything.
And then you have an active Earth that's turning over material.
And then you start with a biogenesis and everything.
So it's all like a pretty remarkable story.
I'm not sure that I can pick like a single unique piece of it that I find most interesting.
I guess for me as an artificial intelligence researcher, it's probably the last piece.
We have lots of animals that are not building technological society, but we do.
And it seems to have happened very quickly.
It seems to have happened very recently.
And something very interesting happened there that I don't fully understand.
I almost understand everything else, I think intuitively, but I don't understand exactly
that part and how quick it was.
Both explanations would be interesting.
One is that this is just a continuation of the same kind of process.
There's nothing special about humans.
That would be deeply understanding that would be very interesting.
That we think of ourselves as special, but it was obvious.
It was already written in the code that you would have greater and greater intelligence
emerging.
And then the other explanation, which is something truly special happened, something like a rare
event, whether it's like crazy rare event, like space Odyssey, what would it be?
If you say like the invention of fire or the, as Richard and Rangham says, the beta
males deciding a clever way to kill the alpha males by collaborating and so just optimizing
the collaboration, the multi-agent aspect of the multi-agent, and that really being constrained
on resources and trying to survive the collaboration aspect is what created the complex intelligence.
But it seems like it's a natural algorithm, the evolution process.
What could possibly be a magical thing that happened?
Like a rare thing that would say that humans are actually human level intelligence actually
a really rare thing in the universe.
Yeah, I'm hesitant to say that it is rare by the way, but it definitely seems like it's
kind of like a punctuated equilibrium where you have lots of exploration and then you have
certain leaps, sparse leaps in between.
So of course, like origin of life would be one, you know, DNA, sex, eukaryotic, eukaryotic
life, the endosymbiosis event where the archaeon ate the old bacteria, you know, just the whole
thing.
And then of course, emergence of consciousness and so on.
So it seems like definitely there are sparse events where massive amount of progress was
made.
But yeah, it's kind of hard to pick one.
So you don't think humans are unique, got to ask you, how many intelligent alien civilizations
do you think are out there?
And is there intelligence different or similar to ours?
Yeah, I've been preoccupied with this question quite a bit recently, basically the Fermi
Bear Docs and just thinking through, and the reason actually that I am very interested
in the origin of life is fundamentally trying to understand how common it is that there
are technological societies out there in space.
And the more I study it, the more I think that there should be quite a lot.
Why haven't we heard from them?
Because I agree with you.
It feels like I just don't see why what we did here on Earth is so difficult to do.
Yeah, and especially when you get into the details of it, I used to think origin of life
was very, it was this magical rare event.
But then you read books like, for example, Niklein, the vital question, life ascending, etc.
And he really gets in and he really makes you believe that this is not that rare basic
chemistry.
You have an active Earth and you have your alkaline vents and you have lots of alkaline
waters mixing with a devotion and you have your proton gradients and you have the little
porous pockets of these alkaline vents that concentrate chemistry.
And basically as he steps through all of these little pieces, you start to understand that
actually this is not that crazy.
You could see this happen on other systems.
And he really takes you from just a geology to primitive life.
And he makes it feel like it's actually pretty plausible.
And also like the origin of life didn't, was actually fairly fast after formation of
Earth, if I'm recurrently just a few hundred million years or something like that after
basically when it was possible, life actually arose.
So that makes me feel that that is not the constraint, that is not the limiting variable
and that life should actually be fairly common.
And then where the drop offs are is very interesting to think about.
I currently think that there's no major drop offs basically and so there should be quite
a lot of life.
And basically where that brings me to then is the only way to reconcile the fact that
we haven't found anyone and so on is that we just can't, we can't see them.
We can't observe them.
Just a quick brief comment, Nick Lane and a lot of biologists I talked to, they really
seem to think that the jump from bacteria to more complex organisms is the hardest jump.
The you carry it like this.
Yeah.
Which I don't, I get it, they're much more knowledgeable than me about like the intricacies of biology.
But that seems like crazy because how many single cell organisms are there like and how
much time you have surely it's not that difficult like an ability in years is not even that
long of a time really just all these bacteria under constrained resources battling it out.
I'm sure they can invent more complex.
I don't understand.
It's like how to move from a hello world program to like invent a function or something
like that.
Yeah, so I don't, yeah, so I'm with you.
I just feel like I don't see any.
If the origin of life, that would be my intuition.
That's the hardest thing.
But if that's not the hardest thing because it happens so quickly, then it's got to be
everywhere.
And yeah, maybe we're just too dumb to see it.
Well, it's just, we don't have really good mechanisms for seeing this life.
I mean, by what how?
So I'm not an expert just to preface this, but just from what I mean at it was, I want
to meet an expert on alien intelligence and how to communicate.
I'm very suspicious of our ability to find these intelligence is out there and to find
these earth like radio waves, for example, are terrible.
Their power drops off as basically one over our square.
So I remember reading that our current radio waves would not be the ones that we are broadcasting
would not be measurable by our devices today.
Only like, was it like one tenth of a light year away?
Like not even basically tiny distance because you really need like a targeted transmission
of massive power directed somewhere for this to be picked up on long distances.
And so I just think that our ability to measure is not amazing.
I think there's probably other civilizations out there.
And then the big question is why don't they build one moment probes and why don't they
interstellar travel across the entire galaxy?
And my current answer is it's probably interstellar travel is like really hard.
You have the interstellar medium.
If you want to move at close to speed of light, you're going to be encountering bullets
along the way because even like tiny hydrogen atoms and particles of dust are basically
have like massive kinetic energy at those speeds.
And so basically you need some kind of shielding, you need that you have all the cosmic radiation.
It's just like brutal out there.
It's really hard.
And so my thinking is maybe interstellar travel is just extremely hard.
And you have to build years to build hard.
It feels like it feels like we're not a billion years away from doing that.
It just might be that it's very, you have to go very slowly potentially as an example
through space.
Right.
I was supposed to close this speed of light.
Yeah.
So I'm suspicious basically of our ability to measure life and I'm suspicious of the ability
to just permeate all of space in the galaxy or across galaxies.
And that's the only way that I can certainly, I can currently see a way around it.
Yeah.
It's kind of mind blowing to think that there's trillions of intelligent alien civilizations
out there kind of slowly traveling through space to meet each other and some of them
meet, some of them go to war, some of them collaborate.
Or they're all just independent, they're all just like little pockets.
I don't know.
Well, statistically, if there's like, if it's there's trillions of them, surely some
of them, some of the pockets are close enough to get some of them happen to be close,
you know, and close enough to see each other and then once you see, once you see something
that is definitely complex life, like if we see something, we're probably going to be
severe, like intensely aggressively motivated to figure out what the hell that is and try
to meet them.
Well, it will be your first instinct to try to like at a generational level, meet them
or defend against them or will be your instinct as a president of the United States.
And the scientist, I don't know which hat you prefer in this question.
Yeah.
The question, it's really hard.
I will say, like, for example, for us, we have lots of primitive life forms on Earth.
Next to us, we have all kinds of ants and everything else and we share space with them.
And we are hesitant to impact on them and to, we are trying to protect them by default
because they are amazing, interesting, dynamical systems that took a long time to evolve and
they are interesting and special.
And I don't know that you want to destroy that by default.
And so I like complex dynamical systems that took a lot of time to evolve.
I think I'd like to preserve it if I can afford to.
And I'd like to think that the same would be true about galactic resources and that they
would think that we're kind of an incredible, interesting story that took time, it took
a few billion years to unravel and you don't want to just destroy it.
I could see two aliens talking about Earth right now and saying, I'm a big fan of complex
dynamical systems.
So I think it's with a value to preserve these and we basically are a video game they watch
or show a TV show that they watch.
Yeah, I think you would need like a very good reason, I think, to destroy it.
Like why don't we destroy these ant farms and so on?
It's because we're not actually like really in direct competition with them right now.
We do it accidentally and so on.
But there's plenty of resources and so why would you destroy something that is so interesting
and precious?
Well, from a scientific perspective, you might probe it.
You might interact with it like you might want to learn something from it, right?
So I wonder there could be certain physical phenomena that we think is a physical phenomena
but it's actually interacting with us to like poke the finger and see what happens.
I think it should be very interesting to scientists, other alien scientists what happened here.
And you know, it's what we're seeing today as a snapshot, basically, it's a result of
a huge amount of computation over like billion years or something like that.
So it could have been initiated by aliens.
This could be a computer running a program like when, okay, if you had the power to do this
when you, okay, for sure, at least I would, I would pick a earth like planet that has
the conditions based my understanding of the chemistry prerequisites for life.
And I would see it with life and run it, right?
Like, when you 100% do that and observe it and then protect, I mean, that's not just
the hell of a good TV show.
It's a good scientific experiment.
And it's physical simulation, right?
Maybe the evolution is the most like actually running it is the most efficient way to understand
computation or to compute stuff or understand life or, you know, what life looks like.
And what branches it can take.
It does make me kind of feel weird that we're part of a science experiment, but maybe
it's everything's a science experiment inside of, does that change anything for us?
For a science experiment?
I don't know, two descendants of Apes talking about being inside a science experiment.
I'm suspicious of this idea of like a deliberate penspermia as you described it, sir.
Yes.
It's a divine intervention in some way in the historical record right now.
I do feel like the story in these books, like Nikolai's books and so on sort of makes
sense.
And it makes sense how life arose on Earth uniquely.
And yeah, I don't need a, I mean, I don't need to reach for more exotic explanations
right now.
Sure, but NPCs inside a video game don't, don't, don't observe any divine intervention
either.
We might just be all NPCs running a kind of code.
Maybe eventually they will, currently NPCs are really dumb, but once they're running
GPTs, maybe they will be like, hey, this is really suspicious with the hell.
So you famously tweeted, it looks like if you bombard Earth with photons for a while,
you can emit a rotester.
So if like in Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy, we would summarize the story of Earth.
So in that book, it's mostly harmless.
What do you think is all the possible stories, like a paragraph long or a sentence long,
that Earth could be summarized as, once it's done, it's computation.
So like all the possible full, if Earth is a book, right, probably there has to be an
ending.
I mean, there's going to be an end to Earth and we could end in all kinds of ways.
You can end soon.
You can end later.
What do you think are the possible stories?
Well, definitely there seems to be, yeah, you're sort of, it's pretty incredible that these
self-replicating systems will basically arise from the dynamics and then they perpetuate
themselves and become more complex and eventually become conscious and build a society.
And I kind of feel like in some sense, it's kind of like a deterministic wave that
kind of just like happens on any sufficiently well-arranged system like Earth.
So I kind of feel like there's a certain sense of inevitability in it, and it's really
beautiful.
And it ends somehow, right?
So it's a, it's a chemically diverse environment where complex dynamical systems can evolve and
become more further, further complex.
But then there's a certain, what is it, there's certain terminating conditions.
Yeah, I don't know what the terminating conditions are, but definitely there's a trend line
of something.
And we're part of that story.
And like, where does that, where does it go?
So, you know, we're famously described often as a biological bootloader for AIs.
And that's because humans, I mean, we're an incredible biological system and we're capable
of computation and, you know, and love and so on.
But we're extremely inefficient as well.
Like we're talking to each other through audio, it's just kind of embarrassing, honestly.
We're manipulating like seven symbols, serially, we're using vocal chords.
It's all happening over like multiple seconds.
It's just like kind of embarrassing when you step down to the frequencies at which computers
operate or are able to operate on.
And so basically, it does seem like synthetic intelligences are kind of like the next stage
of development.
And I don't know where it leads to, like at some point, I suspect the universe is some
kind of a puzzle.
And these synthetic AIs will uncover that puzzle and solve it.
And then what happens after, right?
Like what?
Because if you just like fast forward earth, many billions of years, it's like, it's quiet.
And then it's like, to turmoil, you see like city lights and stuff like that.
And then what happens at like at the end, like, is it like a, or is it like a calming?
Is it explosion?
Is it like earth like open like a giant, because you said emit roasters like we'll start
emitting like like a giant number of like satellites.
Yes.
It's some kind of a crazy explosion.
And we're living.
We're like, we're stepping through a explosion and we're like living day to day and it
doesn't look like it.
But it's actually, if you, I saw a very cool animation of earth and life on earth and
basically nothing happens for a long time.
And then the last like two seconds, like basically cities and everything and the lower
earth orbit just gets cluttered.
And just the whole thing happens in the last two seconds and you're like, this is exploding.
This is a state of explosion.
So if you play, yeah, yeah, if you play at a normal speed, it'll just look like an explosion.
It's a firecracker.
We're living in a firecracker where it's going to start emitting all kinds of interesting
things.
Yeah.
And then the explosion doesn't, it might actually look like a little explosion with lights
and fire and energy emitted all that kind of stuff.
But when you look inside, the details of the explosion, there's actual complexity happening
where there's like, yeah, human life or some kind of life, we hope it's another destructive
firecracker.
It's kind of like a constructive firecracker.
All right.
So given that, I think hilarious.
This guy, it is really interesting to think about like what the puzzle of the universe
is.
Did the creator of the universe give us a message?
Like for example, in the book Contact Carl Sagan, there's a message for humanity for
any civilization in the digits, in the expansion of pi and base 11 eventually, which is kind
of interesting thought, maybe, maybe we're supposed to be giving a message to our creator.
Maybe we're supposed to somehow create some kind of a quantum mechanical system that
alerts them to our intelligent presence here.
Because if you think about it from their perspective, it's just say like quantum field
theory, massive like solar atomic bomb like thing.
And like how do you even notice that we exist?
We might not even be able to pick us up in that simulation.
And so how do you prove that you exist, that you're intelligent and that you're part
of the universe?
So this is like a touring test for intelligence from Earth.
Yeah.
I got the creators.
I mean, maybe this is like trying to complete the next origin and sentence.
This is a complicated way of that.
Like Earth is just is basically sending a message back.
Yeah, the puzzle is basically like alerting the creator that we exist.
Yeah.
The puzzle is just to just break out of the system and just stick it to the creator in some
way.
Basically, like if you're playing a video game, you can somehow find an exploit and find
a way to execute on the host machine in your arbitrary code.
There's some, for example, I believe someone got Mario, a game of Mario to play pong just
by exploiting it and then creating a, basically writing code and being able to execute
arbitrary code in the game.
And so maybe we should be, maybe that's the puzzle, is that we should be, find a way
to exploit it.
So, so I think like some of these synthetic ares will eventually find the universe to
be some kind of a puzzle and then solve it in some way.
And that's kind of like the end game somehow.
Do you often think about it as a, as a simulation?
So as, or the universe being a kind of computation that has might have bugs and exploits?
Yes.
Yeah, I think so.
I think that physics is essentially, I think it's possible that physics has exploits
and we should be trying to find them, arranging some kind of a crazy quantum mechanical system
that somehow gives you buffer overflow, somehow gives you a rounding error in the floating
point.
Yeah.
That's right.
And like more and more sophisticated exploits, those are jokes, but that could be actually
very close.
Yeah.
We'll find some way to extract infinite energy.
For example, when you train reinforcement learning agents and physical simulations and
you ask them to, say, run quickly on the flat ground, they'll end up doing all kinds
of weird things in part of that optimization, right?
They'll get on their back leg and they'll slide across the floor.
And it's because the optimization, the reinforcement learning optimization on that agent, has figured
out a way to extract infinite energy from the friction forces and basically their poor
implementation and they found a way to generate infinite energy and just slide across the
surface.
And it's not what you expected.
It's just sort of like a perverse solution.
And so maybe we can find something like that.
Maybe we can be that little dog in this physical simulation.
The cracks or escapes the intended consequences of the physics that the universe came up
with.
Yeah.
We'll figure out some kind of shortcut to some weirdness.
And then, man, but see the problem with that weirdness is the first person to discover
the weirdness, like sliding in the back legs, that's all we're going to do.
Yeah.
It's very quickly because everybody does that thing.
So the paperclip maximizer is a ridiculous idea, but that very well could be what then
we'll just all switch that because it's so fun.
Well, no person will discover it, I think, by the way.
I think it's going to have to be some kind of a super intelligent AGI of a Thorpe generation.
Like we're building the first generation AGI, maybe you know, third generation.
Yeah, so the bootloader for an AI, that AI will be a bootloader for another AI.
And then there's no way for us to introspect like what that might have been.
I think it's very likely that these things, for example, say you have these AGIs, it's
very likely that, for example, they will be completely inert.
I like these kinds of sci-fi books sometimes where these things are just completely inert.
They don't interact with anything.
And I find that kind of beautiful because they probably figured out the meta game of
the universe in some way potentially.
They're doing something completely beyond our imagination.
And they don't interact with simple chemical life forms like why would you do that?
So I find those kinds of ideas compelling.
What's their source of fun?
What are they doing?
What's the source of pleasure?
Probably planning solving in the universe.
But inert, so can you define what it means inert, so they escape the interactual physics
to us as in they will behave in some very strange way to us because they're beyond their
playing the meta game.
And the meta game is probably, say, like, arranging quantum mechanical systems in some very weird
ways to extract infinite energy, solve the digital expansion of pie to whatever amount.
They will build their own like little fusion reactors or something crazy, like they're
doing something beyond comprehension and not understandable to us and actually brilliant
under the hood.
What if quantum mechanics itself is the system and we're just thinking it's physics, but
we're really parasites on, not parasite, we're not really hurting physics.
We're just living on this organisms, this organism and we're like trying to understand
it, but really it is an organism.
With the deep, deep intelligence, maybe physics itself is the organism that's doing the
super interesting thing.
And we're just like one little thing and sitting on top of it, trying to get energy from
it.
We're just kind of like these particles in the wave that I feel like is mostly deterministic
and takes a universe from some kind of a big bang to some kind of a super intelligent
replicator, some kind of a stable point in the universe given these laws of physics.
You don't think, as Einstein said, God doesn't play dice, so you think it's mostly deterministic.
There's no randomness in the thing.
I think it's deterministic.
Oh, there's tons of, well, I'm, I'm going to be careful with randomness.
Sudo-random?
Yeah, I don't like random.
I think maybe the laws of physics are deterministic.
Yeah, I think their deterministic is just got really uncomfortable with this question.
Do you have an idea about whether the universe is random or not?
There's no randomness.
You like goodwill hunting.
It's not your fault, Andre.
It's not your fault, man.
So you don't like randomness.
Yeah, I think it's unsettling.
I think it's a deterministic system.
I think that things that look random, like say the collapse of the wave function, etc.,
I think they're actually deterministic, just entanglement and so on and some kind of
a multiverse theory, something, something.
Okay, so why does it feel like we have a free will?
Like if I raise this hand, I chose to do this now.
What, that doesn't feel like a deterministic thing.
It feels like I'm making a choice.
It feels like it.
Okay.
So it's all feelings.
It's just feelings.
Yeah.
So when RL agent is making a choice, is that it's not really making a choice.
The choice is all already there.
Yeah, you're interpreting the choice and you're creating a narrative for having made it.
Yeah.
And now we're talking about the narrative.
It's very meta.
Looking back, what is the most beautiful or surprising idea in deep learning or AI?
In general, you've come across, you've seen this field explode and grow in interesting
ways.
Just what cool idea is like we made you sit back and go, small, bigger, small.
Well, the one that I've been thinking about recently, the most probably is the transformer
architecture.
So basically neural hours have a lot of architectures that were trendy have come and gone for different
sensory modalities like for vision, audio, text.
You would process them with different looking neural nuts.
And recently we've seen these convergence towards one architecture, the transformer.
And you can feed it video or you can feed it, you know, images or speech or text and
just gobble it up.
And it's kind of like a bit of a general purpose computer that is also trainable and very
efficient to run on our hardware.
And so this paper came out in 2016, I want to say attention is all you need, attention
is all you need.
You criticize the paper title in retrospect that it wasn't, it didn't foresee the bigness
of the impact that it was going to have.
Yeah, I'm not sure if the authors were aware of the impact that that paper would go on
to have, probably they weren't, but I think they were aware of some of the motivations
and design decisions behind the transformer and they chose not to, I think, expand on
it in that way in the paper.
And so I think they had an idea that there was more than just the surface of just like
over just doing translation and here's a better architecture.
You're not just doing translation.
This is like a really cool, differentiable, optimizable, efficient computer that you've
proposed.
And maybe they didn't have all of that foresight, but I think it's really interesting.
Isn't it funny, sorry to interrupt, that title is memeable, that they went for such
a profound idea, they went with a, I don't think anyone used that kind of title before,
right?
Attention is all you need.
Yeah, it's like a meme or something, essentially.
Yeah, it's not funny, that one, like maybe if it was a more serious title, we don't have
the impact.
Honestly, yeah, there is an element of me that honestly agrees with you and prefers it
this way.
Yes.
If it was too grand, it would overpromise and then underdevelop potentially.
So you want to just meme your way to greatness.
That should be a t-shirt.
So you tweeted the transformers and magnificent neural network architecture because it is
a general purpose, differentiable computer, it is simultaneously expressive in the forward
pass, optimizable via back propagation and gradient descent and efficient high parallelism
compute graph.
Can you discuss some of those details expressed of optimizable, efficient memory or in general,
whatever comes to your heart?
You want to have a general purpose computer that you can train on arbitrary problems, like
say the task of next work prediction or detecting if there's a cat in a image or something like
that.
And you want to train this computer so you want to set its weights.
And I think there's a number of design criteria that sort of overlap in the transformer
simultaneously that made it very successful.
And I think the authors were kind of deliberately trying to make this really powerful architecture.
And so basically it's very powerful in the forward pass because it's able to express
very general computation as sort of something that looks like message passing.
You have nodes and they all store vectors and these nodes get to basically look at each
other and it's each other's vectors and they get to communicate and basically nodes get
to broadcast, hey, I'm looking for certain things.
And then other nodes get to broadcast, hey, these are the things I have, those are the keys
and the values.
So it's not just attention.
Yeah, exactly.
Chessformer is much more than just the attention component that's got many pieces architectural
that went into it.
The residual connection of the weights arranged.
There's a multi-layer perceptron and they're the way it's stacked and so on.
But basically there's a message passing scheme where nodes get to look at each other, decide
what's interesting and then update each other.
And so I think the, when you get to the details of it, I think it's a very expressive function
so it can express lots of different types of algorithms and forward pass.
Not only that, but the way it's designed with the residual connections, layer normalizations,
the softmatics, attention and everything.
It's also optimizable.
This is a really big deal because there's lots of computers that are powerful that you
can't optimize or they are not easy to optimize using the techniques that we have, which
is backpackation and gradient descent.
These are our first order methods, very simple optimizers, really.
And so you also need it to be optimizable.
And then lastly, you wanted to run efficiently on our hardware.
Our hardware is a massive throughput machine, like GPUs.
They prefer lots of parallelism.
So you don't want to do lots of sequential operations.
You want to do a lot of operations, seriously.
And the transformer is designed with that in mind as well.
And so it's designed for our hardware and is designed to both be very expressive in
a forward pass, but also very optimizable in the backward pass.
And you said that the residual connection support a kind of ability to learn short algorithms
fast and first, and then gradually extend them longer during training.
What's the idea of learning short algorithms?
Right.
Think of it as a, so basically a transformer is a series of blocks, right?
And these blocks have attention and a little multi-layer perceptron.
And so you go off into a block and you come back to this residual pathway, and then you
go off and you come back.
And then you have a number of layers arranged sequentially.
And so the way to look at it, I think, is because of the residual pathway in the backward
pass, the gradients sort of flow, allowing it uninterrupted because addition distributes
the gradient equally to all of its branches.
So the gradient from the supervision at the top just floats directly to the first layer.
And all the residual connections are arranged so that in the beginning and during initialization,
they contribute nothing to the residual pathway.
So what it kind of looks like is imagine the transformer is kind of like a Python function,
like a death.
And you get to do various kinds of like lines of code.
So you have a hundred layers deep transformer, typically they would be much shorter, say
20.
So if 20 lines of code, then you can do something in them.
And so think of during the optimization, basically, what it looks like is first you
optimize the first line of code, and then the second line of code can kick in and the
third line of code can kick in.
And I kind of feel like because of the residual pathway and the dynamics of the optimization,
you can sort of learn a very short algorithm that gets the approximate answer.
But then the other layers can sort of kick in and start to create a contribution.
And at the end of it, you're optimizing over an algorithm that is 20 lines of code.
Except these lines of code are very complex because this is an entire block of a transformer.
You can do a lot in there.
What's really interesting is that this transformer architecture actually has been a remarkably
resilient.
Basically, the transformer that came out in 2016 is the transformer you would use today,
except you reshuffle some delayer norms.
The delayer normalizations have been reshuffle to a pre-norm formulation.
And so it's been remarkably stable, but there's a lot of bells and whistles that people
have attached on it and try to improve it.
I do think that basically it's a big step in simultaneously optimizing for lots of properties
of a desirable neural network architecture.
And I think people have been trying to change it, but it's proven remarkably resilient.
But I do think that there should be even better architectures potentially.
But it's you admire the resilience here.
Yeah.
There's something profound about this architecture that leads to resilient.
So maybe we can everything can be turned into a problem that transformers can solve.
Currently, it definitely looks like the transformer is taking over AI, and you can feed basically
arbitrary problems into it.
And it's a general, the Frenchable computer, and it's extremely powerful.
And this conversion in AI has been really interesting to watch for me personally.
What else do you think could be discovered here about transformers, like what's the
surprising thing?
Or is it a stable, I want a stable place.
Is there something interesting where my discover about transformers, like aha moments,
maybe has to do with memory, maybe knowledge representation, that kind of stuff?
Definitely, the zeitgeist today is just pushing, like basically right now the zeitgeist
is do not touch the transformer, touch everything else.
Yes.
So people are scaling up the datasets, making them much, much bigger.
They're working on the evaluation, making the evaluation much, much bigger.
And they're basically keeping the architecture unchanged.
And that's how we've, that's the last five years of progress in AI kind of.
What do you think about one flavor of it, which is language models?
Have you been surprised?
Has your sort of imagination been captivated by, you mentioned DPT, and all the bigger and
bigger and bigger language models?
And what are the limits of those models, do you think?
So just the task of natural language.
Basically, the way GPT is trained, right, is you just done a massive amount of text
data from the internet, and you try to predict the next word in a sequence, roughly speaking.
You're predicting a little work chunks, but roughly speaking, that's it.
And what's been really interesting to watch is, basically it's a language model.
Language models have actually existed for a very long time.
There's papers on language modeling from 2003, even earlier.
Can you explain in that case what language model is?
Yeah, so language model, just basically the rough idea is just predicting the next word
in a sequence, roughly speaking.
So there's a paper from, for example, Ben Geo and the team from 2003, where for the first
time, they were using a neural network to take, say, like three or five words and predict
the next word.
And they're doing this on much smaller data sets, and the neural net is not a transformer.
It's a multi-year perceptron, but it's the first time that a neural network has been
applied in that setting.
But even before neural networks, there were language models, except they were using N-gram
models.
So N-gram models are just a count-based models.
So if you try to take two words and predict a third one, you just count up how many times
you've seen any two word combinations and what came next, and what you predict as coming
next is just what you've seen the most of in the training set.
And so language modeling has been around for a long time.
Neural networks have done language modeling for a long time.
So really what's new or interesting or exciting is just realizing that when you scale it up
with powerful enough neural net transformer, you have all these emergent properties where
basically what happens is if you have a large enough data set of text, you are in the
task of predicting the next word, you are multitasking a huge amount of different kinds
of problems.
You are multitasking understanding of chemistry, physics, human nature.
Lots of things are sort of clustered in that objective.
It's a very simple objective, but actually you have to understand a lot about the world
to make that prediction.
You just said the you word understanding, are you in terms of chemistry and physics and
so on, what do you feel like it's doing?
Is it searching for the right context in like what is it, what is the actual process happening
here?
Yeah, so basically it gets a thousand words and is trying to predict a thousand at first.
And in order to do that very, very well over the entire data set available on the internet,
you actually have to basically kind of understand the context of what's going on in there.
And it's a sufficiently hard problem that you, if you have a powerful enough computer
like a transformer, you end up with interesting solutions.
And you can ask it to do all kinds of things and it shows a lot of emergent properties
like in context learning that was the big deal with GPT and the original paper when they
published it is that you can just sort of prompt it in various ways and ask it to do various
things and it will just kind of complete the sentence, but in a process of just completing
the sentence, it's actually solving all kinds of really interesting problems that we
care about.
Do you think it's doing something like understanding, like when we use the word understanding for
us humans?
I think it's doing some understanding.
In its way, it understands I think a lot about the world and it has to in order to predict
the next word in the sequence.
So let's train on the data from the internet.
What do you think about this approach in terms of data sets of using data from the internet?
Do you think the internet has enough structured data to teach AI about human civilization?
Yes, so I think the internet has a huge amount of data.
I'm not sure if it's a complete enough set.
I don't know that text is enough for having a sufficiently powerful AGI as an outcome.
Of course, there is audio and video and images and all that kind of stuff.
Yeah, so text by itself, I'm a little bit suspicious about.
There's a ton of things we don't put in text in writing just because they're obvious
to us about how the world works and the physics of it and the things fall.
We don't put that stuff in text because why would you?
We shared that understanding.
And so text is communication medium between humans and it's not a all encompassing medium
of knowledge about the world.
But as you pointed out, we do have video and we have images and we have audio.
And so I think that definitely helps a lot, but we haven't trained models sufficiently
across all of those modalities yet.
So I think that's what a lot of people are interested in.
But I wonder what that shared understanding of what we may call common sense has to
be learned inferred in order to complete the sentence correctly.
So maybe the fact that it's implied on the internet, the model is going to have to learn
that, not by reading about it, by inferring it in the representation.
So like common sense, just like we, I don't think we learn common sense.
Like nobody says, tells us explicitly, we just figure it all out by interacting with
the world.
Right.
And so here's a model of reading about the way people interact with the world and might
have to infer that.
I wonder, yeah, you briefly worked in a project called the World of Bits training in our
L system to take actions on the internet versus just consuming the internet like you talked
about.
Do you think there's a future for that kind of system interacting with the internet to
help the learning?
Yes.
I think that's probably the final frontier for a lot of these models because, so as you mentioned,
when I was at OpenAI, I was working on this project World of Bits.
And basically it was the idea of giving neural networks access to a keyboard and a mouse.
And the idea is.
Okay.
Possibly go wrong.
So basically you, you perceive the input of the screen pixels and basically the state
of the computer is sort of visualized for human consumption in images of the web browser
and stuff like that.
And then you give the neural or the ability to press keyboards and use the mouse and we're
trying to get it to, for example, complete bookings and interact with user interfaces.
And would you learn from that experience?
Like what was some fun stuff?
This is super cool idea.
Yeah.
It's like, yeah, I mean, the step between observer to actor is a super fascinating step.
Well, it's the universal interface in the digital realm, I would say.
And there's a universal interface in the physical realm, which in my mind is a humanoid
form factor kind of thing.
We can later talk about optimists and so on.
But I feel like there's a, they're kind of like similar philosophy in some way where
the world, the physical world is designed for the human form and the digital world is designed
for the human form of seeing the screen and using keyboard and mouse.
And so it's the universal interface that can basically command the digital infrastructure
we've built up for ourselves.
And so it feels like a very powerful interface to command and to build on top of.
Now to your question is to like what I learned from that.
It's interesting because the world of bits was basically too early, I think at OpenAI
at the time.
This is around 2015 or so, and the zeitgeist at that time was very different in AI from
the zeitgeist today.
At the time, everyone was super excited about reinforcement learning from scratch.
This is the time of the Atari paper where neural networks were playing Atari games and beating
humans in some cases, AlphaGo and so on.
So everyone's very excited about training neural networks from scratch using reinforcement
learning directly.
It turns out that reinforcement learning is extremely an efficient way of training
neural networks because you're taking all these actions and all these observations and
you get some sparse rewards once in a while.
So you do all this stuff based on all these inputs.
And once in a while you're like told you did a good thing, you did a bad thing.
And it's just an extremely hard problem when you can't learn from that.
You can burn a forest and you can sort of brute force through it.
And we saw that I think with Go and Dota and so on and does work, but it's extremely
inefficient and not how you want to approach problems, practically speaking.
And so that's the approach that at the time we also took to world of bits.
We would have an agent initialize randomly.
So with keyboard mash and mouse mash and try to make a booking.
And it's just like revealed the insanity of that approach very quickly where you have
to stumble by the correct booking in order to get a reward of you did it correctly.
And you're never going to stumble by it by chance at random.
So even with a simple web interface, there's too many options.
There's just too many options and it's two sparse reward signal.
And you're starting from scratch at the time.
And so you don't know how to read.
You don't understand pictures, images, buttons.
You don't understand what it means to make a booking.
But now what's happened is it is time to revisit that and openly I was interested in this.
Companies like adept are interested in this and so on.
And the idea is coming back because the interface is very powerful.
But now you're not training an agent from scratch.
You are taking the GPT as an initialization.
So GPT is pre-trained on all of text.
And it understands what's a booking.
It understands what's a submit.
It understands quite a bit more.
And so it already has those representations.
They are very powerful.
And that makes all the training significantly more efficient and makes the problem tractable.
Should the interaction be like the way humans see it, with the buttons and the language
or should be with the HTML JavaScript and the CSS?
Yeah.
What do you think is the better?
So today all of this interaction is mostly on the level of HTML, CSS and so on.
That's done because of computational constraints.
But I think ultimately everything is designed for human visual consumption.
And so at the end of the day, there's all the additional information is in the layout
of the web page and what's next to you and what's our red background and all this kind
of stuff and what it looks like visually.
So I think that's the final frontier as we are taking in pixels and we're giving out
the keyboard mouse commands.
But I think it's impractical still today.
Do you worry about bots on the internet given these ideas, given how exciting they are,
do you worry about bots on Twitter being not the stupid bots that we see now with the crypto
bots, but the bots that might be out there actually that we don't see that they're interacting
in interesting ways.
So this kind of system feels like it should be able to pass the, I'm not a robot click
button, whatever.
Which do you actually understand how that test works?
I don't quite like there's a check box or whatever that you click.
It's presumably tracking like mouse movement and the timing and so on.
So exactly this kind of system we're talking about should be able to pass that.
So yeah, what do you feel about bots that are language models plus have some interactability
and are able to tweet and reply and so on, do you worry about that world?
Yeah, I think it's always been a bit of an arms race between sort of the attack and
the defense. So the attack will get stronger, but the defense will get stronger as well
our ability to detect that.
How do you defend?
How do you detect?
How do you know that your Karpati account on Twitter is as human?
How would you approach that?
Like if people were claim, you know, how would you defend yourself in the court of law
that I'm a human this account is.
Yeah, at some point, I think it might be, I think the society will evolve a little bit
like we might start signing digitally signing some of our correspondence or things that
we create.
Right now, it's not necessary, but maybe in the future, it might be.
I do think that we are going towards the world where we share the digital space with
AI's synthetic beings.
And they will get much better and they will share our digital realm and they'll eventually
share our physical realm as well.
It's much harder, but that's kind of like the world we're going towards and most of them
will be benign and awful and some of them will be malicious and it's going to be an
arms race trying to detect them.
So I mean, the worst isn't the AI is the worst is the AI is pretending to be human.
So I don't know if it's always malicious.
There's obviously a lot of malicious applications, but it could also be, you know, if I was an
AI, I would try very hard to pretend to be human because we're in a human world.
Yeah.
I wouldn't get in your respect as an AI.
I want to get some love and respect.
I don't think the problem is intractable.
People are thinking about the proof of personhood and we might start digitally signing our
stuff and we might all end up having like, yeah, basically some solution for proof of
personhood.
It doesn't seem to me intractable.
It's just something that we haven't had to do until now, but I think once the need
like really starts to emerge, which is soon, I think people will think about it much
more.
So, but that too will be a race because obviously you can probably spoof or fake the proof
of personhood.
So you have to try to figure out how to probably, I mean, it's weird that we have like social
security numbers and like passports and stuff.
It seems like it's harder to fake stuff in the physical space, but in the digital space
it just feels like it's going to be very tricky, very tricky to out because it seems to be
pretty low cost of fake stuff.
What are you going to put an AI in jail for like trying to use a fake personhood proof?
I mean, okay, fine, you'll put a lot of AI's in jail, but there'll be more AI's, I
would say like exponentially more.
The cost of creating a bot is very low.
Unless there's some kind of way to track accurately, like you're not allowed to create any program
without showing tying yourself to that program.
Like any program that runs on the internet, you'll be able to trace every single human
program that was involved with that program.
Right.
Yeah, maybe you have to start declaring when, you know, we have to start drawing those
boundaries and keeping track of, okay, what are digital entities versus human entities?
And what is the ownership of human entities and digital entities and something like that?
I don't know, but I think I'm optimistic that this is possible.
And in some sense, we're currently in like the worst time of it because all these bots
suddenly have become very capable, but we don't have the fences yet built up as a society.
But I think that doesn't seem to me intractable, it's just something that we have to deal
with.
It seems weird that the Twitter bot, like really crappy Twitter bots are so numerous.
I guess.
So I presume that the engineers at Twitter are very good.
So it seems like what I would infer from that is it seems like a hard problem.
They're probably catching, all right, if I were to sort of steal man the case, it's a
hard problem and there's a huge cost to false positive to removing a post by somebody that's
not a bot.
That's a crazy, very bad user experience.
So they're very cautious about removing, so maybe it's, and maybe the bots are really
good at learning what gets removed and not such that they can stay ahead of the removal
process very quickly.
My impression of it, honestly, is there's a lot of room for it, I mean, yeah, just that's
what I, it's not so, my impression of it, it's not so, but you have, yeah, that's my
impression as well, but it feels like maybe you're seeing the, the tip of the iceberg, maybe
the number of bots isn't like the trillions and you have to like, just, it's a constant
assault of bots and you, yeah, yeah, I don't know, um, I, you have to steal man the case
because the bots, I'm seeing a pretty like obvious, I could write a few lines of code that
catch these bots.
I mean, definitely there's a lot of room for it, but I will say I agree that if you are
a sophisticated actor, you could probably create a pretty good bot right now, um, you
know, using tools like GPTs because it's a language model.
You can generate faces that look quite good now, uh, and you can do this at scale.
And so I think, um, yeah, it's quite plausible and it's going to be hard to defend.
There's a Google engineer that claimed that the Lambda was sentient.
Do you think there's any inkling of truth to what he felt?
And more importantly, to me, at least, do you think language models will achieve sentience
or the illusion of sentience?
Sunish.
Yeah.
To me, it's a little bit of a canary in a coal mine kind of moment, honestly, a little
bit, uh, because, uh, so this engineer spoke to like a chatbot at Google and, uh, we can
convince that, uh, there's a lot of sentient.
Yeah.
Asked some existential philosophical questions and gave like reasonable answers and looked
real and, uh, and so on.
Uh, so to me, it's a, uh, he was, he was, uh, he wasn't sufficiently trying to stress
the system, I think, and, uh, exposing the truth of it as it is today.
Um, but, uh, I think this will be increasingly harder over time, uh, so, uh, yeah, I think
more and more people will basically, uh, become, um, yeah, I think more and more, there
will be more people like that over time as, as this gets better, like form and emotional
connection to, to, to an AI, yeah, perfectly plausible in my mind.
I think these AIs are actually quite good at human, human, human, uh, connection, human
emotion, a ton of text on the internet is about humans and connection and love and so on.
So I think they have a very good understanding in some, in some sense of, of how people speak
to each other about this and, um, they're very capable of creating a lot of that kind of
text.
The, um, there's a lot of like sci-fi from 50s and 60s that imagined AIs in a very different
way.
They are calculating cold Balkan-like machines.
That's not what we're getting today.
We're getting pretty emotional AIs that actually, uh, are very competent and capable of generating,
you know, possible sounding text with respect to all of these topics.
See, I'm really hopeful about AI systems that are like companions that help you grow,
develop as a human being, uh, help you maximize long-term happiness, but I'm also very
worried about AI systems that figure out from the internet that humans get attracted to
drama.
And so these would just be like shit talking AIs that just constantly, did you hear it?
They'll do gossip.
They'll do, uh, they'll try to plant seeds of suspicion to other humans that you love
and trust and, uh, just kind of mess with people, uh, in the, you know, cause, cause that's
going to get a lot of attention.
So drama, maximize drama on the path to maximizing, uh, engagement and us humans will feed
into that machine, yeah, and get it'll be a giant drama shit storm, uh, so I'm worried
about that.
So it's the objective function really defines the way that human civilization progresses
with AI's in it.
Yeah.
I think right now, at least today, they are not sort of, it's not correct to really think
of them as goal seeking agents that want to do something.
They have no long-term memory or anything.
It's literally a good approximation of it is you get a thousand words and you're trying
to pretty get a thousand at first and then you continue feeding it in.
And you are free to prompt it in whatever way you want.
So in text, so you say, okay, you are a psychologist and you are very good and you love humans.
And here's a conversation between you and another human, human colon, something, you
something.
And then it just continues the pattern and suddenly you're having a conversation with
the fake psychologist who's like trying to help you.
And so it's still kind of like in a realm of a tool, it is a, um, people can prompt it
in arbitrary ways and it can create really incredible text, but it doesn't have long-term
goals over long periods of time.
It doesn't try to, um, so it doesn't look that way right now.
Yeah, but you can do short-term goals that have long-term effects.
Yeah.
So if my prompting short-term goal is to get Anger Kapati to respond to me on Twitter
when I, like, I think AI might, that's the goal, but it might figure out that talking
shit to you will be the best, in a highly sophisticated, interesting way.
And then you build up a relationship when you respond once and then it, like, over time
it gets to not be sophisticated and just, like, just talk shit.
And okay, maybe you won't get to Andre, but it might get to another celebrity and might
get into other big accounts, and then he'll just, so we just, that's something.
For example, go get them to respond.
Yeah.
Maximize the probability of actual response.
Yeah, I mean, you could prompt a powerful model like this with their, its opinion about
how to do any possible thing you're interested in.
So they will just, they're kind of on track to become these oracles.
I could sort of think of it that way.
They are oracles, currently is just text, but they will have calculators, they will
access to Google search, they will have all kinds of gadgets and gizmos, they will
be able to operate the internet and find different information, and yeah, in some sense, that's
kind of like currently what it looks like in terms of the development.
Do you think it'll be an improvement eventually over what Google is for access to human knowledge?
Like, it'll be a more effective search engine to access human knowledge.
I think there's a definite scope in building a better search engine today.
And I think Google, they have all the tools, all the people, they have everything they
need, they have all the puzzle pieces, they have people training transformers.
At scale, they have all the data, it's just not obvious if they are capable as an organization
to innovate on their search engine right now.
And if they don't, someone else will.
There's absolute scope for building a significantly better search engine built on these tools.
It's so interesting, a large company where the search, there's already an infrastructure,
it works as it brings out a lot of money.
So where structuring inside a company is their motivation to pivot to say we're going
to build a new search engine.
Yeah, that's hard.
So it's usually going to come from a startup, right?
That's, that would be, yeah, or some other more competent organization.
So I don't know.
So currently, for example, maybe Bing has another shot at it, you know, as an example, Microsoft
Edge.
We're talking offline.
I mean, I definitely, it's really interesting because search engines used to be about,
okay, here's some query, here's, here's web pages that look like the stuff that you have,
but you could just directly go to answer and then have supporting evidence.
And these, these models basically, they've read all the texts and they've read all the
web pages.
And so sometimes when you see yourself going over to search results and sort of getting
like a sense of like the average answer to whatever you're interested in, like that
just directly comes out.
You don't have to do that work.
So they're kind of like, yeah, I think they have a way of distilling all that knowledge
into like some level of insight, basically.
Do you think of prompting as a kind of teaching and learning, like this whole process,
like another layer, you know, because maybe that's what humans are, where you have that
background model and then the world is prompting you.
Yeah, exactly.
I think the way we are programming these computers now, like GPs, is converging to how you program
humans.
I mean, how do I program humans via prompt?
I go to people and I prompt them to do things, I prompt them for information.
And so natural language prompt is how we program humans and we're starting to program computers
directly in that interface.
It's like pretty remarkable, honestly.
So you've spoken a lot about the idea of software 2.0.
All good ideas become like cliches so quickly, like the terms, it's kind of hilarious.
It's like, I think M&M wants that, like, if he gets annoyed by a song he's written very
quickly, that means it's going to be a big hit because it's too catchy.
But can you describe this idea and how you're thinking about it has evolved over the months
and years since you coined it?
Yeah.
So I had a blog post on software 2.0, I think several years ago now.
And the reason I wrote that post is because I kept, I kind of saw something remarkable
happening in software development and how a lot of code was being transitioned to be written
not in sort of like C++ and so on, but it's written in the weights of a neural net, basically
just saying that neural nets are taken over software, they're almost software and taking
more and more and more tasks.
And at the time, I think not many people understood this deeply enough that this is a big deal,
this is a big transition, neural networks were seen as one of multiple classification
algorithms you might use for your data set problem on Kaggle.
Like, this is not that, this is a change in how we program computers.
And I saw neural nets as this is going to take over, the way we program computers is going
to change, it's not going to be people writing a software in C++ or something like that
and directly programming the software, it's going to be accumulating training sets and
data sets and crafting these objectives by which you train these neural nets.
And at some point there's going to be a compilation process from the data sets and the objective
and the architecture specification into the binary, which is really just the neural
net, you know, weights and the forward pass of the neural net, and then you can deploy
that binary.
And so I was talking about that sort of transition and that's what the post is about.
And I saw this sort of play out in a lot of fields, you know, autopilot being one of them,
but also just simple image classification.
People thought originally, you know, in the 80s and so on that they would write the algorithm
for detecting a dog in an image.
And they had all these ideas about how the brain does it and first we detect corners and
then we detect lines and then we stitch them up and they were like really going at it,
they were like thinking about how they're going to write the algorithm.
And this is not the way you build it.
And there was a smooth transition where, okay, first we thought we were going to build
everything.
Then we were building the features, so like hog features and things like that that detect
these little statistical patterns from image patches.
And then there was a little bit of learning on top of it, like a support vector machine
or binary classifier for cat versus dog and images on top of the features.
So we wrote the features, but we trained the last layer, sort of the classifier.
And then people are like, actually let's not even design the features because we can't
honestly, we're not very good at it.
So let's also learn the features.
And then you end up with basically a convolutional neural net where you're learning most of
it.
You're just specifying the architecture and the architecture has tons of fill-in blanks
which is all the knobs and you let the optimization write most of it.
And so this transition is happening across the industry everywhere.
And suddenly we end up with a ton of code that is written in neural net weights.
And I was just pointing out that the analogy is actually pretty strong.
And we have a lot of developer environments for software 1.0, like we have IDEs, how you
work with code, how you debug code, how do you run code, how do you maintain code.
We have GitHub.
So I was trying to make those analogies in the new realm.
Like what is the GitHub?
I'll software 2.0 turns out it's something that looks like hugging face right now.
And so I think some people took it seriously and built cool companies and many people originally
attacked the post.
It actually was not built received when I wrote it.
And I think maybe it has something to do with the title but the post was not well received
and I think more people have been coming around to it over time.
Yeah.
So you were the director of AI at Tesla where I think this idea was really implemented
at scale, which is how you have engineering teams doing software 2.0.
So can you sort of linger on that idea of I think we're in the really early stages of everything
you just said, which is like GitHub IDEs, like how do we build engineering teams that work
in software 2.0 systems and the data collection and the data annotation, which is all part
of that software 2.0.
Like what do you think is the task of programming a software 2.0?
Is it debugging in the space of hyperparameters or is it also debugging in the space of data?
Yeah, the way by which you program the computer and influence its algorithm is not by writing
the commands yourself.
You're changing mostly the data set.
You're changing the loss functions of like what the neural net is trying to do, how
it's trying to predict things.
But basically the data sets and the architecture, so the neural net.
And so in the case of the autopilot, a lot of the data sets had to do with, for example,
detection of objects and lane line markings and traffic lights and so on.
So you accumulate massive data sets of, here's an example, here's the desired label.
And then here's roughly how the architect, here's roughly what the algorithm should look
like.
And that's a completion neural net.
So the specification of the architecture is like a hint as to what the algorithm should
roughly look like.
And then the fill in the blanks process of optimization is the training process.
And then you take your neural net that was trained, it gives all the right answers on
your data set and you deploy it.
So there's, in that case, perhaps at all machine learning cases, there's a lot of tasks.
So is coming up, formulating a task, like a, for a multi-headed neural network is formulating
a task part of the programming, how you break down a problem into a set of tasks.
Yeah.
I'm going to high level, I would say, if you look at the software running in the autopilot,
I give a number of talks on this topic, I would say originally, a lot of it was written
in software 1.0, there's, imagine lots of C++, right?
And then gradually, there was a tiny neural net that was, for example, predicting, given
a single image, is there like a traffic light or not, or is there a lane line marking
or not?
And this neural net didn't have too much to do in the scope of the software, it was making
tiny predictions on individual image.
And then the rest of the system stitched it up.
So okay, we're actually, we don't have just a single camera with eight cameras.
We actually have eight cameras over time.
And so what do you do with these predictions?
How do you put them together?
How do you do the fusion of all that information and how do you act on it?
All of that was written by humans in C++.
And then we decided, okay, we don't actually want to do all of that fusion in C++ code,
because we're actually not good enough to write that algorithm.
We want the neural net to write the algorithm.
And we want to port all of that software into the 2.0 stack.
And so then we actually had neural net that now take all the eight camera images simultaneously
and make predictions for all of that.
And actually, they don't make predictions in the space of images, they now make predictions
directly in 3D.
And actually, they don't, in three dimensions, around the car.
And now actually, we don't manually fuse the predictions in 3D over time.
We don't trust ourselves to write that tracker.
So actually, we give the neural net the information over time.
So it takes these videos now and makes those predictions.
And so you're serving just like putting more and more power into the neural net, more
processing.
And at the end of it, the eventual sort of goal is to have most of the software potentially
be in the 2.0 land, because it works significantly better.
Humans are just not very good at writing software, basically.
So the prediction is happening in this like 4D land with three dimensional world over
time.
How do you do annotation in that world?
What have you, so data annotation, whether it's self-supervised or manual by humans is a
big part of the software 2.0 world?
Right.
I would say by far in the industry, if you're like talking about the industry and how, what
is the technology of what we have available, everything is supervised learning.
So you need a data sets of input, desired output, and you need lots of it.
And there are three properties of it that you need.
You need it to be very large.
You need it to be accurate, no mistakes, and you need it to be diverse.
You don't want to just have a lot of correct examples of one thing.
You need to really cover the space of possibility as much as you can.
And the more you can cover the space of possible inputs, the better the algorithm will work
at the end.
Now, once you have really good data sets that you're collecting, curating, and cleaning,
you can train your neural net on top of that.
So a lot of the work goes into cleaning those data sets now.
As you pointed out, it's probably, it could be, the question is, how do you achieve a
ton of, if you want to basically predict and 3D, you need data and 3D to back that up.
So in this video, we have eight videos coming from all the cameras of the system.
And this is what they saw.
And this is the truth of what actually was around.
There was this car, there was this car, this car.
These are the lane line markings.
This is geometry of the road.
There's traffic light in this redimensional position.
You need the ground truth.
And so the big question that the team was solving, of course, is, how do you, how do you
arrive at that ground truth?
Because once you have a million of it, and it's large, clean, and diverse, then training
in your own net on it works extremely well, and you can ship that into the car.
And so there's many mechanisms by which we collected that training data.
You can always go for a human annotation.
You can go for simulation as a source of ground truth.
You can also go for what we call the offline tracker that we've spoken about at the AI
day and so on, which is basically an automatic reconstruction process for taking
those videos and recovering the three-dimensional sort of reality of what was around that
car.
So basically think of doing like a three-dimensional reconstruction as an offline thing.
And then understanding that, okay, there's 10 seconds of video.
This is what we saw.
And therefore, here's all the lane line scars and so on.
And then once you have that annotation, you can train in your own net to imitate it.
And how difficult is the reconstruction?
The three reconstruction.
It's difficult.
But it can be done.
So there's overlap between the cameras and you do the reconstruction, and there's perhaps
if there's any inaccuracy, so that's caught in the annotation step.
Yes.
The nice thing about the annotation is that it is fully offline.
You have infinite time.
You have a chunk of one minute and you're trying to just offline in a supercomputer somewhere,
figure out where were the positions of all the cars, all the people.
And you have your full one minute video from all the angles.
And you can run all the neural nets you want and they can be very efficient, massive neural
nets.
There can be neural nets that can't even run in the car later at test time.
So they can be even more powerful neural nets than what you can eventually deploy.
So you can do anything you want, three dimensional reconstruction, neural nets, anything you want
just to recover that truth, and then you supervise that truth.
What have you learned?
You said no mistakes about humans doing annotation, because I assume humans are, there's like
a range of things they're good at in terms of clicking stuff on screen.
Isn't that, how interesting is that you have a problem of designing an annotator where
humans are accurate, enjoy it, like what are the even the metrics or efficient or productive
all that kind of stuff?
Yeah.
So I grew the annotation team at Tesla from basically zero to a thousand while I was there.
That was really interesting, you know, my background is a PhD student researcher.
So growing that common organization was pretty crazy.
But yeah, I think it's extremely interesting and part of the design process very much behind
the autopilot as to where you use humans.
Humans are very good at certain kinds of annotations.
They're very good, for example, at two dimensional annotations of images, they're not good at annotating
cars over time in three dimensional space, very, very hard.
And so that's why we were very careful to design the tasks that are easy to do for humans
versus things that should be left to the offline tracker.
Like maybe the computer will do older triangulation in three-degree construction, but the human
will say exactly these pixels of the image are car, exactly these pixels are human.
And so co-designing the data annotation pipeline was very much bread and butter was what I
was doing daily.
Do you think there's still a lot of open problems in that space?
Just in general, annotation where the stuff the machines are good at, machines do and
the humans do what they're good at, and there's maybe some iterative process.
Right.
I think to a very large extent, we went through a number of iterations and we learned a ton
about how to create these data sets.
I'm not seeing big open problems.
Like originally when I joined, I was like, I was really not sure how this would turn out.
Yeah.
But by the time I left, I was much more secure and actually we sort of understand the
philosophy of how to create these data sets.
And I was pretty comfortable with where that was at the time.
So what are strengths and limitations of cameras for the driving task in your understanding?
When you formulate the driving task as a vision task with eight cameras, you've seen that
the entire, you know, most of the history of the computer vision field when it has to
do a new one that works, what, just if you step back, what are the strengths and limitations
of pixels, of using pixels to drive?
Yeah, pixels, I think, are a beautiful sensory, beautiful sensor, I would say.
The things like cameras are very, very cheap and they provide a ton of information, ton
of bits.
Also, it's an extremely cheap sensor for a ton of bits and each one of these bits as
a constraint on the state of the world.
And so you get lots of megapixel images, very cheap and it just gives you all these constraints
for understanding what's actually out there in the world.
So vision is probably the highest bandwidth sensor, it's a very high bandwidth sensor.
And I love that pixels is a constraint on the world.
This is highly complex, high bandwidth constraint on the world, on the state of the world.
It's not just that, but again, this real, real importance of, it's the sensor that humans
use.
Therefore, everything is designed for that sensor.
Yeah.
The text, the writing, the flashing signs, everything is designed for vision.
And so you just find it everywhere.
And so that's why that is the interface you want to be in, talking again about these
universal interfaces.
And that's where we actually want to measure the world as well.
And then develop software for that sensor.
But there's other constraints on the state of the world that humans use to understand
the world.
I mean, vision ultimately is the main one, but we're like referencing our understanding
of human behavior and some common sense physics that could be inferred from vision from
a perception perspective, but it feels like we're using some kind of reasoning to predict
the world.
Not just the pixels.
I mean, you have a powerful prior for how the world evolves over time, etc.
So it's not just about the likelihood term coming up from the data itself, telling you
about what you are observing, but also the prior term of where the likely things to see
and how do they likely move and so on.
And the question is how complex is the range of possibilities that might happen in the
driving task?
That's still, is that to you still an open problem of how difficult it is driving, like
philosophically speaking, do all the time you work on driving, do you understand how hard
driving is?
Yeah, driving is really hard, because it has to do with predictions of all these other
agents in the theory of mind and what they're going to do, and are they looking at you?
Are they looking?
Are they thinking?
Yeah.
There's a lot that goes there at the full tail off, you know, the expansion of the
noise that we have to be comfortable with it eventually, the final problems are of
that form.
I don't think those are the problems that are very common.
I think eventually they're important, but it's like really in the tail end.
In the tail end, the rare edge cases, from the vision perspective, what are the toughest
parts of the vision problem of driving?
Well, basically, the sensor is extremely powerful, but you still need to process that information.
And so going from brightnesses of these special values to, hey, here the three dimensional
world is extremely hard, and that's what the neural networks are fundamentally doing.
And so the difficulty really is in just doing an extremely good job of engineering the
entire pipeline, the entire data engine, having the capacity to train these neural nets, having
the ability to evaluate the system and iterate on it.
So I would say just doing this in production at scale is like the hard part.
It's an execution problem.
So the data engine, but also the sort of deployment of the system such that has low latency
performance.
So it has to do all these steps.
Yeah, for the neural nets specifically, just making sure everything fits into the chip
on the car.
Yeah.
And you have a finite budget of flops that you can perform, and memory bandwidth and
other constraints.
And you have to make sure it flies.
And you can squeeze in as much computer as you can into the tiny.
What have you learned from that process?
Because maybe that's one of the bigger, like new things coming from a research background
where there's a system that has to run under heavily constrained resources, has to run
really fast.
What kind of insights have you learned from that?
Yeah, I'm not sure if it's, if there's too many insights, you're trying to create a neural
net that will fit in what you have available.
And you're always trying to optimize it.
And we talked a lot about it on the AI day and basically the triple backflips that the
team is doing to make sure it all fits and utilizes the engine.
So I think it's extremely good engineering.
And then there's all kinds of little insights peppered in on how to do it properly.
Let's actually zoom out because I don't think we talked about the data engine.
The entirety of the layouts of this idea that I think is just beautiful.
With humans in the loop, can you describe the data engine?
Yeah, the data engine is what I call the almost biological feeling like process by which
you perfect the training sets for these neural networks.
So because most of the programming now is in the level of these data sets and make sure
they're large diverse and clean, basically you have a data set that you think is good.
You train your neural net, you deploy it.
And then you observe how well it's performing and you're trying to always increase the quality
of your data set.
So you're trying to catch scenarios, basically there are basically rare.
And it is in these scenarios that the neural nets will typically struggle in because they
weren't told what to do in those rare cases in the data set.
But now you can close the loop because if you can now collect all those at scale, you
can then feed them back into the reconstruction process I described and reconstruct the truth
in those cases and add it to the data set.
And so the whole thing ends up being like a staircase of improvement of perfecting your
training set.
And you have to go through deployments so that you can mine the parts that are not yet
represented well on the data set.
So your data set is basically imperfect.
It needs to be diverse.
It has pockets.
There are missing and you need to pat out the pockets.
You can sort of think of it that way in the data.
What role do humans play in this?
So what's this biological system, like a human body is made up of cells, how do you optimize
the human system, the multiple engineers collaborating, figuring out what to focus on,
what to contribute, which task to optimize in this neural network, who is in charge of
figuring out which task needs more data.
And can you speak to the hyperparameters, the human system?
It really just comes down to extremely good execution from an engineering team who knows
what they're doing.
We understand intuitively the philosophical insights underlying the data engine and the process
by which the system improves and how to, again, delegate the strategy of the data collection
and how that works and then just making sure it's all extremely well executed.
And that's where most of the work is not even the philosophizing or the research or the
ideas of it, it's just extremely good execution, it's so hard when you're dealing with data
at that scale.
So your role in the data engine executing well on it is difficult and extremely important.
Is there a priority of like a vision board of saying like, we really need to get better
at stoplights, like the prioritization of tasks, is that essentially, and that comes from
the data?
That comes to a very large extent to what we are trying to achieve in the product format
where we're trying to, the release we're trying to get out in the feedback from the Q18
worth it, where the system is struggling or not, the things we're trying to improve.
And the Q18 gives some signal, some information in aggregate about the performance of the
system in various conditions.
That's right.
And then, of course, all of us drive it and we can also see it.
It's really nice to work with a system that you can also experience yourself, you know,
it drives you home.
Is there some insight you can draw from your individual experience that you just can't
quite get from an aggregate statistical analysis of the data?
Yeah.
It's so weird, right?
Yes.
It's not scientific, in a sense, because you're just one anecdotal sample.
Yeah, I think there's a ton of, it's a source of truth as your interaction with the system.
And you can see it, you can play with it, you can perturb it, you can get a sense of it,
you have an intuition for it.
I think numbers, just like have a way of numbers and plots and graphs are, you know, much
harder.
Yeah.
It divides a lot of, it's like, if you train a language model, it's a really powerful
way is by you interacting with it.
Yeah.
You're trying to build up an intuition.
I think, like, Elon also, like, he always wanted to drive the system himself.
He drives a lot.
And I don't want to say almost daily.
So he also sees this as a source of truth.
You driving the system and it performing and, yeah.
So what do you think?
Tough questions here.
So Tesla last year removed radar from, from the sensor suite and now just announced
there's going to remove all ultrasonic sensors relying solely on vision.
So camera only, does that make the perception probably harder or easier?
I would almost reframe the question in some way.
So the thing is basically, you would think that additional sensors, by the way, can
I just interrupt?
God.
I wonder if a language model will ever do that if you prompt it.
Let me reframe your question.
That would be epic.
This is the wrong problem.
Sorry.
It's like a little bit of a wrong question because basically, you would think that these
sensors are an asset to you.
Yeah.
But if you fully consider the entire product and its entirety, these sensors are actually
potentially liability because these sensors aren't free.
They don't just appear on your car.
You need suddenly, you need to have an entire supply chain.
You have people procuring it.
There can be problems with them.
They may need replacement.
They are part of the manufacturing process.
They can hold back the line in production.
You need to source them.
You need to maintain them.
You have to have teams that ride the firmware, all of it, and then you also have to incorporate
them, fuse them into the system in some way.
And so it actually, like, blows the organ, a lot of it.
And I think Elon is really good at simplifying, simplify, best part is no part.
And he always tries to throw away things that are not essential because he understands
the entropy in organizations and in an approach.
And I think, in this case, the cost is high and you're not potentially seeing it if
you're just a computer vision engineer.
And I'm just trying to improve my network and, you know, is it more useful or less useful
or how useful is it?
And the thing is, once you consider the full cost of a sensor, it actually is potentially
a liability and you need to be really sure that it's giving you extremely useful information.
In this case, we looked at using it or not using it and the delta was not massive.
And so it's not useful.
Is it also bloat in the data engine, like having more sensors, and is a distraction?
And these sensors, you know, they can change over time, for example.
You can have one type of, say radar, you can have other type of radar, they change over
time.
And I suddenly need to worry about it.
And I'm suddenly going to have a column in your SQLite telling you, oh, what sensor
type was it?
And they all have different distributions.
And then they can, they just, they contribute noise and entropy into everything.
And they bloat stuff.
And also organizationally has been really fascinating to me that it can be very distracting.
Um, if you, if all, if you only want to get to work as vision, all the resources are on
it and you're building out a data engine.
And you're actually making forward progress because that is the, the sensor with the most
bandwidth, the most constraints on the world.
And you're investing fully into that and you can make that extremely good.
If you're, uh, you're only a finite amount of sort of spend of, uh, focus across different
facets of the system.
And, uh, this kind of reminds me of Rich Sutton's a bit of lesson that just seems like simplifying
the system.
Yeah.
In the long run, of course, you know, no, with the long run, it seems to be always the
right solution.
Yeah.
Yes.
In that case, it was for RL, but it seems to apply generally across all systems that do
computation.
Yeah.
So where, uh, what do you think about the LiDAR as a crutch debate, uh, the battle between
point clouds and pixels?
Yeah, I think this debate is always like slightly confusing to me because it seems like
the actual debate should be about like, do you have the fleet or not?
That's like the really important thing about whether you can achieve, uh, really good
functioning of an AI system at the scale.
So data collection systems.
Yeah.
Do you have a fleet or not is significantly more important, whether you have LiDAR or
not?
It's just another sensor.
Um, and, uh, yeah, I think similar to the radar discussion, basically, I, um, I, yeah,
I don't think it, um, basically it doesn't offer extra, uh, extra information.
It's extremely costly.
It has all kinds of problems.
You have to worry about it.
You have to calibrate it, et cetera.
It creates bloat and entropy.
You have to be really sure that you need this, uh, this, um, sensor.
In this case, I basically don't think you need it.
And I think honestly, I will make a stronger statement.
I think the others, uh, some of the other, uh, companies that are using it are probably
going to drop it.
Yeah.
And you have to consider the sensor in the full, in considering, can you build a big
fleet that collects a lot of data and can you integrate that sensor with it, that, that
data and that sensor into a data engine that's able to quickly find different parts of the
data that then continuously improves whatever the model that you're using.
Yeah.
Another way to look at it is like vision is necessary in a sense that, uh, the drive, uh,
the world is designed for human visual consumption.
So you need vision.
It's necessary.
And then also it is sufficient, uh, because it has all the information that you, that you
need for driving and humans, obviously, is vision to drive.
So it's both necessary and sufficient.
So you want to focus resources and you have to be really sure if you're going to bring
in other sensors.
You could, you could, you could add sensors to infinity at some point you need to draw
the line.
And I think in this case, you have to really consider the full, um, cost of any one sensor
that you're adopting.
And do you really need it?
And I think the answer in this case is no.
So what do you think about the idea that the other companies are forming high resolution
maps and constraining heavily the geographic regions in which they operate?
Is that approach not in your, in your view, um, not going to scale over time to the entirety
of the United States?
I think I'll take too long.
As you mentioned, like they pre-map all the environments and they need to refresh the
map and they have a perfect centimeter level accuracy map of everywhere they're going
to drive.
Crazy.
How are you going to, when we're talking about the autonomy actually changing the world,
we're talking about the deployment on a, on the global scale autonomous systems for transportation.
And if you need to maintain a centimeter accurate map for earth, we're like for many cities
and keep them updated.
It's a huge, uh, dependency that you're taking on huge dependency.
It's, it's a massive massive dependency.
And now you need to ask yourself, do you really need it?
And humans don't need it, um, right?
So it's, it's very useful to have a low level map of like, okay, the connectivity of your
road.
You know that there's a fork coming up, uh, when you drive an environment, you sort of have
that high level understanding.
It's like a small Google map and, uh, Tesla uses Google map, uh, like similar kind of resolution
information in its system, but it will not pre-map environments to send me to a level
accuracy.
It's a crotch.
It's a distraction.
It costs entropy and it, uh, diffuses the team and dilutes the team and you're not focusing
on what's actually necessary, which is the computer version problem.
What did you learn about machine learning, about engineering, about life, about yourself
as one human being from working with Elon Musk?
I think the most I've learned is about how to sort of run organizations efficiently and
how to create efficient organizations and how to fight entropy in an organization.
So human engineering in the fight against entropy.
Yeah.
There's a, there's a, I think Elon is a very efficient warrior, uh, in the fight against
entropy in organizations.
What does the entropy in an organization look like, exactly?
It's, it's process, it's, it's process and inefficiencies in the human beings and that
kind of stuff.
Yeah, meetings, he hates meetings.
He keeps telling people to skip meetings if they're not useful.
He basically runs the world's biggest, uh, startups, I would say, uh, Tesla SpaceX
started the world's biggest startups, Tesla actually is multiple startups, I think is
better to look at it that way.
And so I think he's, he's extremely good at, uh, at that and, uh, yeah, he's a very
good, um, intuition for streamlining processes, making everything efficient, uh, best part
is no part, uh, simplifying, focusing, um, and just kind of removing barriers, uh, moving
very quickly, making big moves.
Now, all this is a very start-upy sort of seeming things, but at scale.
So strong drive to simplify, from your perspective, I mean, that, um, that also probably applies
to just designing systems and machine learning and otherwise, like simplifies, simplifies.
Yes.
What do you think is the secret to maintaining the startup culture in a company that grows?
Is there, can you introspect that?
I do think he needs someone in a powerful position with a big hammer, like Elon, who's
like the cheerleader for that idea and ruthlessly pursues it.
If no one has a big enough hammer, everything turns into committees, democracy within the
company, uh, process, talking to stakeholders, decision-making, just everything, just crumbles.
Yeah.
If you have a big person who is also really smart and has a big hammer, uh, things move
quickly.
So you said your favorite scene in interstellar is the intense docking scene with the AI
and Cooper talking, saying, uh, Cooper, what are you doing?
Talking, it's not possible, no, it's necessary, it's such a good line.
By the way, just so many questions there, why an AI in that scene, presumably is supposed
to be able to compute a lot more than the human is saying it's not optimal, why the human,
I mean, that's a movie, but shouldn't the AI know which better than the human?
Anyway, uh, what do you think is the value of setting, seemingly impossible goals?
So like, uh, our initial intuition, which seems like something that, uh, you have taken
on that Elon espouses that where the initial intuition of the community might say this
is very difficult, and then you take it on anyway with a crazy deadline.
You're just from a human engineering perspective, um, uh, have you seen the value of that?
I wouldn't say that setting impossible goals exactly is, is a good idea, but I think setting
very ambitious goals is a good idea.
I think there's a, what I call sub linear scaling of difficulty, uh, which means that 10x
problems are not 10x hard, usually 10x, 10x harder problem is like two or three x harder
to execute on, because if you want to actually like, if you want to improve a system by 10%,
it costs some amount of work, and if you want to 10x improve the system, it doesn't cost,
you know, 100x amount of the work, and it's because you fundamentally changed the approach,
and if you start with that constraint, then some approaches are obviously dumb and not
going to work.
And it forces you to re-evaluate, um, and I think it's a very interesting way of approaching
problem solving.
But it requires a weird kind of thinking, it's just going back to your like PhD days, it's
like, how do you think which ideas in, in the machine learning community are solvable?
Mm-hmm.
Yes.
It requires, what, what is that? I mean, there's the cliche of first principles thinking,
but like, it requires to basically ignore what the community is saying, because it doesn't
the community, doesn't A community in science usually draw lines of what isn't as impossible.
Right.
And like, it's very hard to break out of that without going crazy.
Yeah.
I mean, I think a good example here is, you know, the deep learning revolution in some
sense, because you could be in computer vision at that time when during the, uh, deep learning,
sort of revolution of 2012 and so on, you could be improving a computer vision stack by
10 percent, or we can just be saying, actually, all of this is useless.
And how do I do 10x better computer vision?
Well, it's not probably by tuning a hog feature detector.
I need a different approach.
Um, I need something that is scalable, going back to, uh, Richard Sutton's, um, and understanding
sort of like the philosophy of the, uh, bitter lesson and then being like, actually, I need
a much more scalable system like neural network, that in principle works, and then having
some deep believers that can actually execute on that mission and make it work.
So that's the 10x solution.
What do you think is the timeline to solve the problem of autonomous driving?
That's still in part open question.
Yeah.
I think the tough thing with timelines of self driving, obviously, is that no one has created
self driving.
Yeah.
So it's not like, what do you think is a timeline to build this bridge?
Well, we've built million bridges before.
Here's how long that takes.
It's, you know, it's, uh, no one has built autonomy.
It's not obvious, uh, some parts turn out to be much easier than others.
It's really hard to forecast.
You do your best based on trend lines and so on and based on intuition.
But that's why fundamental is just really hard to forecast this.
No one has to even still like being inside of it is hard to, uh, to do some things turn
out to be much harder and some things turn out to be much easier.
Do you try to avoid making forecasts because like Elon doesn't avoid them, right?
And heads of car companies in the past have not avoided it either, uh, Ford and other
places have made predictions that we're going to solve a level for driving by 2020, 2021,
whatever.
And now they're all kind of backtrack in that prediction.
I you as a, as an AI person, do you for yourself privately make predictions or do they get
in the way of like your actual ability to think about a thing?
Yeah.
I would say like what's easy to say is that this problem is tractable and that's an easy
prediction to make.
It's tractable.
It's going to work.
Yes.
It's just really hard.
Something's not to be harder than something's not to be easier, uh, so, uh, but it's definitely
feels tractable and it feels like at least the team at Tesla, which is what I saw internally
is definitely on track to that.
How do you form a strong representation that allows you to make a prediction about tractability?
So like you're the leader of a lot, a lot of humans.
You have to kind of say this is actually possible.
Like how do you build up that intuition?
It doesn't have to be even driving.
It could be other tasks, it could be, um, and I want to, what difficult tasks did you work
on your life?
I mean, classification, achieving certain, just an image net, certain level of superhuman
level performance.
Yeah.
Expert intuition.
It's just intuition.
It's belief.
So just like thinking about it long enough, like studying, looking at sample data, like
you said, driving, uh, my intuition is really flawed on this, but like I don't have a good
intuition about tractability is it could be either, it could be anything.
It could be solvable, like, uh, you know, the driving task could, could be simplified into
something quite trivial.
Like, uh, the solution to the problem would be quite trivial and at scale, more and more
cars driving perfectly might make the problem much easier.
Yes.
And the more cars you have driving, like people learn how to drive correctly, not correctly,
but in a way that's more optimal for, uh, heterogeneous system of autonomous and semi-autonomous
and manually driven cars, that could change stuff.
Then again, also I've spent a ridiculous number of hours just staring at pedestrians crossing
streets, thinking about humans.
And it feels like the way we use our eye contact, it sends really strong signals, and there's
certain quirks in edge cases of behavior, and of course, a lot of the fatalities that
happen have to do with drunk driving and, um, both on the pedestrian side and the driver
side.
So there's that problem of driving at night and all that kind of stuff.
So I wonder, you know, let's say the space of possible solution to autonomous driving
includes so many human factor issues that it's almost impossible to predict.
It could be super clean, nice solutions.
Yeah.
I would say definitely like to use a game analogy, there's some fog of war, but you definitely
also see the frontier of improvement.
And you can measure historically how much you've made progress.
And I think, for example, at least what I've seen in, uh, roughly five years of Tesla,
when I joined it barely kept lane on highway.
I think going up from Pellalto to SF was like three or four interventions anytime the road
would do anything geometrically or turn too much, it would just like not work.
And so going from that to like a pretty competent system in five years and seeing what happens
also under the hood, and what the scale of which the team is operating now with respect
to data and compute to everything else, uh, is just, uh, massive progress.
So this, uh, you're climbing a mountain and it's fog, but you make a lot of progress.
It's fog.
You're making progress and you see what the next directions are.
And you're looking at some of the remaining challenges and they're not like, uh, they're
not perturbing you and they're not changing your philosophy and you're not contorting
yourself.
If you're like, actually, these are the things I've always told you to do.
Yeah, the fundamental components of solving the problem seem to be there from data engine
to the compute to the, the compute on the car to the compute for the training, all that
kind of stuff.
So you've done, uh, over the years you've been a Tesla, you've done a lot of amazing, uh,
take through ideas and engineering, all of it, um, from the data engine to the human
side, all of it.
Can you speak to why you chose to leave Tesla?
Basically, as I described that, Ren, I think over time during those five years, I've kind
of, uh, gotten myself into a little bit of a managerial position, uh, most of my days
were, you know, meetings and growing the organization and making, um, decisions about
a sort of high level strategic decisions about the team and what it should be working
on and so on.
And, uh, it's, it's kind of like a corporate executive role and I can do it.
I think I'm okay at it, uh, but it's not like fundamentally what I, what I enjoy.
And so I think, uh, when I joined, um, there was no computer vision team because Tesla
was just going from the transition of using mobile, I, a third party vendor for all of
its computer vision to having to build its computer vision system.
So when I showed up, there were two people training deep neural networks and they were
training them at a computer, at their, at their legs like, yeah, that's, there's a
kind of basic classification task.
Yeah.
And so I kind of like grew that into what I think is a fairly respectable deep learning
team, massive computer cluster, a very good, um, data annotation organization.
And, uh, I was very happy with where that was.
It became quite autonomous.
And so I kind of stepped away and I, uh, you know, I'm very excited to do much more technical
things again.
Yeah.
And kind of like, we focus on AGI.
What was this soul searching like?
Cause you took a little time off and think like what, um, how many mushrooms did you take?
I mean, what, uh, what was going through your mind?
The human lifetime is finite.
Yeah.
You did a few incredible things.
You're, you're one of the best teachers of AI in the world.
You're one of the best, and I don't mean that, I mean, then the best possible way.
You're one of the best tinkers in the AI world, meaning like, understanding the fundamental,
the methods of how something works by building it from scratch and playing with it, with
the basic intuitions.
It's like Einstein Feynman, we're all really good at this kind of stuff.
Like small example of a thing to, to play with it, to try to understand it, uh, so that
and obviously now with, with us, you help build a team of machine learning, um, uh, like
engineers and assistant that actually accomplished something in the real world.
So given all that, like, what was the soul searching like?
Well, it was hard because obviously I love the company a lot, and I love, I love Elon,
I love Tesla.
I won't, um, it was so hard to leave.
I love the team, basically, um, but yeah, I think I actually, I will be potentially
like interested in revisiting it, maybe coming back at some point, uh, working optimists,
working in AGI at Tesla, uh, I think Tesla is going to do incredible things.
It basically like, uh, it's a massive, large scale robotics kind of company for the
ton of in house talent for doing really incredible things.
And I think, uh, human robots are going to be amazing.
Uh, I think autonomous transportation is going to be amazing.
All this is happening at Tesla.
So I think it's just a really amazing organization.
So being part of it and helping it alone, I think was very, basically, I enjoyed that
a lot.
Yeah, it was basically difficult for those reasons because I love the company, uh, but,
you know, I'm happy to potentially get something coming back for act two, but I felt like
at this stage, I built the team, it felt autonomous and, uh, I became a manager and I wanted
to do a lot more technical stuff.
I wanted to learn stuff.
I wanted to teach stuff, uh, and, uh, I, I just kind of felt like it was a good time
for, uh, for a change of pace a little bit.
What do you think is, uh, the best movie sequel of all time speaking of part two?
It's like, cause most of them suck.
Movie sequels?
Movie sequels, yeah.
And you tweeted about movies, so just in a tiny tangent, is there, what's your, what,
what's like a favorite movie sequel, Godfather part two, um, are you a fan of Godfather?
Cause you didn't even tweet or mention the Godfather.
Yeah.
I don't love that movie.
I know it hasn't added that out.
We're going to edit out the hate towards the Godfather, how dare you just make a strong
statement.
I don't know why.
I don't know why, but I basically don't like any movie before 1995.
Something like that.
Didn't you mention Terminator?
Two.
Okay.
That's like, uh, Terminator two was a little bit later 1990.
No.
I think Terminator two was in the, and I like Terminator one as well.
So, okay.
So like a few exceptions, but by and large, for some reason, I don't like movies before
1995 or something.
They feel very slow.
The camera is like zoomed out.
It's boring.
It's kind of naive.
It's kind of weird.
And also, Terminator was very much ahead of its time.
Yes.
And the Godfather, there's like no AGI.
That's, I mean, but you have good will hunting was one of the movies you mentioned.
And that doesn't have any AGI either.
I guess that's mathematics.
Yeah.
I guess occasionally I do enjoy movies that don't feature or like Anchorman.
That has no, that's, that's, that's so good.
I don't understand.
Um, he's speaking of AGI because I don't understand why wolf arrows so funny.
It doesn't make sense.
It doesn't compute.
There's just something about him.
And he's a singular human because you don't get that many comedies these days.
And I wonder if it has to do about the culture or the like the machine of Hollywood or
it does have to do with just we got lucky with certain people in comedy.
It came together because he is a singular human.
That was a ridiculous tangent, I apologize.
But you mentioned human robots.
So what do you think about Optimus, about Tesla, do you think we'll have robots in the
factory and in the home in 10, 20, 30, 40, 50 years?
Yeah.
I think it's a very hard project.
I think it's going to take a while.
But who else is going to build human robots at scale?
Yeah.
And I think it is a very good form factor to go after because like I mentioned, the world
is designed for human and form factor.
These things would be able to operate our machines.
They would be able to sit down in chairs, potentially even drive cars.
Uh, basically the world is designed for humans.
That's the form factor you want to invest into and make work over time.
Uh, I think, you know, there's another school of thought, which is, okay, pick a problem
and design a robot to it, but actually designing a robot and getting a whole data engine and
everything behind it to work is actually a really hard problem.
So it makes sense to go after general interfaces that, uh, okay, they are not perfect for
any one given task, but they actually have the generality of just with a prompt with
English able to do something across.
And so I think it makes a lot of sense to go after a general, uh, interface, um, in the
physical world, and I think it's a very difficult project.
It means going to take time, um, but I've seen no other, no other company that can execute
on that vision.
I think it's going to be amazing.
Like, uh, basically physical labor.
Like if you think transportation is a large market, try physical labor, but it's not
just physical labor to me, the thing that's also exciting is the social robotics.
So the, the relationship will have on different levels with those robots.
Yeah.
I was really excited to see optimists like, um, people have criticized me for the excitement.
But I've worked with, uh, a lot of research labs that do humanoid, legate robots, uh, Boston
Dynamics, Unitry, a lot, there's a lot of companies that do legate robots.
But that's the, the elegance of the movement is a tiny, tiny part of the big picture.
So integrating the two big exciting things to me about Tesla doing humanoid or any legate
robots is clearly integrating into the data engine.
So the, the data engine aspect.
So the actual intelligence for the perception of the, and the control and the planning and
all that kind of stuff, integrating into the huge, the fleet that you mentioned, right?
Um, and then speaking of fleet, the second thing is the mass manufacturers, just knowing,
uh, culturally, uh, driving towards a simple robot that's cheap to produce at scale.
Yeah.
And doing that well, having experience to do that well, that changes everything.
That's why that's a very different culture and style than Boston Dynamics.
Who, by the way, those, those robots are just the way they move.
It's, uh, like, it'll be a very long time before Tesla could achieve the smoothness of
movement.
And that's not what it's about, it's, it's about, uh, it's about the entirety of the
system.
Like we talked about the data engine and the fleet.
That's super exciting.
Even the initial sort of models, uh, but that too was really surprising that in a few months,
you can get a prototype.
Yep.
And the reason that happened very quickly is, as you alluded to, there's a ton of copy
paste from what's happening on the autopilot, a lot.
The amount of expertise that, like, came out of the woodworks at Tesla for building the
human robot was incredible to see.
Like basically Elon said at one point, we're doing this.
And then next day, basically, like, all these CAD models started to appear and people
talking about like the supply chain and manufacturing.
And people showed up with like screwdrivers and everything like the other day and started
to like put together the body and I was like, whoa, like all these people exist at Tesla.
And fundamentally building a car is actually not that different from building a robot.
The same, and that is true, uh, not just for, uh, the hardware pieces and also let's not
forget hardware, not just for demo, but, um, manufacturing of that hardware at scale.
It's like a whole different thing.
But for software as well, basically this robot currently thinks it's a car.
It's going to have a mid-life crisis at some point.
It thinks it's a car.
Some of the earlier demos, actually, we were talking about potentially doing them outside
in the parking lot because that's where all of the computer vision that was like working
out of the box instead of like inside.
But all the operating system, everything just copy-paste, uh, computer vision, mostly
copy-paste.
I mean, you have to retrain the neural nuts, but the approach on everything and data engine
and offline trackers and the way we go about the occupancy tracker and so on everything
copy-paste.
You just need to retrain the neural nuts, uh, and then the planning control of course
has to change quite a bit.
But there's a ton of copy-paste from what's happening at Tesla.
And so if you were to, if you were to go with goal of like, okay, let's build a million
human robots and you're not Tesla, that's, that's a lot to ask.
If you're Tesla, it's actually like, it's not, it's not that crazy.
And then the follow-up question is on how difficult, just like we're driving, how difficult
is the manipulation task, uh, such that it can have an impact at scale.
I think depending on the context, the really nice thing about robotics is that, um, unless
you do a manufacturer and that kind of stuff, is there is more room for error.
Yeah.
Driving is so safety critical and so that, and also time critical.
Okay, robot is a lot to move slower, which is nice.
Yes.
I think it's going to take a long time, but the way you want to structure the development
is you need to say, okay, it's going to take a long time.
How can I set up the, uh, product development roadmap so that I'm making revenue along
the way?
I'm not setting myself up for a zero one loss function where it doesn't work until it
works.
You don't want to be in that position.
You want to make it useful almost immediately.
And then you want to slowly deploy it, uh, and, uh, at scale, at scale.
And you want to set up your data engine, your improvement loops, the telemetry, the evaluation,
the harness and everything, um, and, uh, you want to improve the product over time
incrementally and you're making revenue along the way.
That's extremely important because otherwise you cannot build these, uh, large undertakings
just like don't make sense economically.
And also from the point of view of the team working on it, they need the dopamine along
the way.
They're not just going to make a promise about this being useful.
This is going to change the world in 10 years when it works.
This is not where you want to be.
You want to be in a place like, I think, out of all this today where it's offering increased
uh, safety and, um, and, uh, convenience of driving today.
People pay for it.
People like it.
People purchase it.
And then you also have the greater mission that you're working towards and you see that.
So the dopamine for the team that that was the source of happiness and, yes.
On the other side.
You're deploying this.
People like it.
People drive it.
People pay for it.
They care about it.
There's all these YouTube videos.
Your grandma drives it.
She gives you feedback.
People like it.
People engage with it.
Do people that drive Teslas like recognize you and give you love like, uh, like, hey,
thanks for the, for the, uh, this nice feature that is doing.
Yeah.
I think the tricky thing is like, some people really love you.
Some people unfortunately like, you're working on something that you think is extremely
valuable, useful, etc.
Some people do hate you.
There's not a lot of people who like hate me and the team and what the whole project.
And I think, uh, they Tesla drivers, uh, in many cases, they're not actually.
Yeah.
And that's actually makes me sad about humans or the current ways that humans interact.
I think that's actually fixable.
I think humans want to be good to each other.
I think Twitter and social media is part of the mechanism that actually somehow makes
the negativity more viral that it doesn't deserve like disproportionately, uh, add of
like a viral viral boost of negativity.
But I got, uh, I wish people would just get excited about, uh, so suppress some of the
jealousy, um, some of the ego and just get excited for others.
And then there's a karma aspect to that you get excited for others, they'll get excited
for you.
Same thing in academia, if you're not careful, there is a, like a dynamical system there.
If you, if you think of in silos and get jealous of somebody else being successful,
that actually perhaps counterintuitively, uh, least the less productivity of us, the community
and you individually.
I feel like if you keep celebrating others that actually makes you more successful.
Yeah.
And I think people haven't, depending on the industry, haven't quite learned that yet.
Some people are also very negative and very vocal.
So they're very prominently featured.
But actually, there's a ton of people who are a cheerleaders, but they're silent cheerleaders.
And, uh, when you talk to people just in the world, they will all tell you it's amazing.
It's great, especially like people who understand how difficult it is to get this stuff working.
Some people who have built products and makers and entrepreneurs, entrepreneurs, like making
this work and changing something is incredibly hard.
Those people are more likely to cheerlead you.
Well, one of the things that makes me sad is some folks in the robotics community, you
know, don't do the cheerleading than they should.
There's, uh, because they know how difficult it is.
Well, they actually sometimes don't know how difficult it is to create a product that
scale, right?
Yeah.
They actually deployed in the real world a lot of the development of robots and AI system
is done on very specific small benchmarks, um, and as opposed to real world conditions.
Yes.
Yeah.
I think it's really hard to work on robotics in academic setting or AI systems that apply
in the real world.
You've criticized you, um, flourished and loved for time, the image net, the famed
image net data set, and it recently had some words, uh, of criticism that the academic
research, ML community gives a little too much love still to the image net or like those
kinds of benchmarks, can you speak to the strengths, the weaknesses of data sets used
in machine learning research?
Actually, I don't know that I recall the specific instance where I was, uh, unhappy or
criticizing image net.
I think image net has been extremely valuable, uh, it was basically a benchmark that allowed
the deep learning community to demonstrate that deep neural works actually work.
It was, uh, there's a massive value in that.
Um, so I think image net was useful, but I'm basically it's become a bit of an emnist
at this point.
So emnist is like little 228 by 28 grayscale digits, there's kind of a joke data set that
everyone like crushes, you know, papers written on emnist, though, right?
Maybe they shouldn't have strong papers, like, uh, papers that focus on like, how do we
learn with a small amount of data that stuff?
Yeah.
Yeah, I could see that being helpful, but not in sort of like mainline, computer vision
research anymore, of course.
I think the way I've heard you somewhere, maybe I'm just imagining things, but I think
you said, like, image net was a huge contribution to the community for a long time, and now it's
time to move past those kinds of, well, image net has been crushed.
I mean, you know, the error rates are, uh, yeah, we're getting like 90% accuracy in, in
1,000 classification way, uh, prediction.
And I've seen those images and it's like really high.
This really, that's really good.
The timer correctly, the top five error rate is now like 1% or something given your experience
with a gigantic real world data set.
Would you like to see benchmarks move in a certain directions that the research community
uses?
Unfortunately, I don't think academics currently have the next image net.
Uh, we've obviously, I think we've crushed emnist.
We've basically kind of crushed image net, uh, and there's no next sort of big benchmark
that the entire community rail is behind and uses, um, you know, for further development
of these networks.
I, yeah, what it would it takes for a data set to captivate the imagination of everybody,
like where they all get behind it, that that could also need like a, like a leader.
Right?
Yeah.
Somebody with popularity.
I mean, uh, yeah, what, what did image net take off?
Is there, is it just the accident of history?
It was the right amount of difficult, uh, it was the right amount of difficult and simple
and, uh, interesting enough, it just kind of like it was, it was the right time for that
kind of a data set.
And from Reddit, uh, what are your thoughts on the role of the synthetic data and game
engines will play in the future of neural net model development?
I think, um, as neural nets converge to humans, uh, the value of simulation to neural nets
will be similar to value of simulation to humans.
So people use simulation for, uh, people do simulation because they can learn something
in that kind of a system, um, and, uh, without having to actually experience it.
Um, but are you referring to the simulation with doing our head?
Is it?
Uh, no, sorry, simulation.
I mean, like video games or, uh, you know, um, other forms of simulation for various
professionals.
Well, so let me push back at that because that maybe there's simulation that we do in
our heads, like, simulate, if I do this, what do I think will happen?
Okay.
That's like internal simulation.
Yeah, internal.
Isn't that what we're doing?
Assume it before we act?
Yeah, but that's independent from like the use of simulation in the sense of like computer
games or using simulation for training set creation or, you know, is it independent
or is it just loosely correlated?
Cause like, uh, isn't that useful to do like, um, counterfactual or like edge case simulation
to like, you know, what happens if there's a nuclear war?
What happens if there's, you know, like those kinds of things, yeah, that's a different
simulation from like Unreal Engine, that's how I interpreted the question.
Yeah.
So like simulation of the average case is that what's Unreal Engine, what do you mean by
Unreal Engine?
So simulating a world, physics of that world, why is that different?
Like cause you also can add behavior to that world and you could try all kinds of stuff,
right?
You could throw all kinds of weird things into it.
So Unreal Engine is not just about simulating, I mean, I guess it is about simulating the
physics of the world.
It's also doing something with that.
Yeah, the graphics, the physics and the agents that you put into the environment and stuff
like that.
Yeah.
See, I think you feel, I feel like you said that it's not that important, I guess, for
the future of AI development.
Is that correct to interpret it either way?
Well, I think, uh, I think humans use simulators for, um, humans use simulators and they find
them useful.
And so computers will use simulators and find them useful.
Okay.
So you're saying it's not like, I don't use simulators very often, I play a video game
every once in a while, but I don't think I derive any wisdom about my own existence
from, from those video games.
It's a momentary escape from reality versus a source of wisdom about reality.
So I don't, so I think that's a very polite way of saying simulation is not that useful.
Yeah, maybe, maybe not, I don't see it as like a fundamental, really important part of
like training neural nets currently.
But I think, uh, as neural nets become more and more powerful, I think you will need fewer
examples to train additional behaviors.
And, uh, simulation is, of course, there's a domain gap in a simulation that is not the
real world.
It's slightly something different.
But, uh, with a powerful enough neural net, uh, you need, um, the domain gap can be bigger,
I think, because neural net will sort of understand that even though it's not the real
world, it like has all this high level structure that I'm supposed to be learning from.
So the neural net will actually, yeah, we'll be able to leverage the synthetic data better
yes, by closing the gap, but understanding in which ways this is not real data.
Exactly.
Uh, right to do better questions next time that was, that was a question that I'm just
kidding.
All right.
Um, so is it possible, do you think speaking of MNIST to construct neural nets and training
processes that require very little data?
So we've been talking about huge data sets like the internet for training.
Yeah.
I mean, yeah, one way to say that is like you said, like the querying itself is another
level of training, I guess, and that requires a little data, but do you see any, uh, value
in doing research and, uh, going down in the direction of, can we use very little data
to train to construct a knowledge base?
100%.
I just think like at some point, you need a massive data set.
And then when you pre train your massive neural net and get something that, you know, is
like a GPT or something, then you're able to be very efficient at training in your return
new task.
Uh, so a lot of these GPTs, you know, you can do tasks like sentiment analysis or translation
or so on just by being prompted with very few examples.
Here's the kind of thing I want you to do, like here's an input sentence, here's the translation
into German, input sentence, translation to German, input sentence blank and the neural
net will complete the translation to German just by looking at sort of the example you've
provided.
And so that's an example of a very few shot, uh, learning in the activations of the neural
net, instead of the weights of the neural net.
And so I think, um, basically, uh, just like humans, neural nets will become very data
efficient at learning any other new task, but at some point, you need a massive data set
to pre train your network to get that and probably we humans have something like that.
Do we, do we have something like that?
Do we have a passive in the background, background model constructing thing?
They just runs all the time in a self supervised way, we're not conscious of it.
I think humans definitely, I mean, obviously we have, uh, we learn a lot during, during
our life span, but also, uh, we have a ton of hardware that helps us initialize, initialization
coming from sort of evolution.
And so I think that's also a really big, big component, a lot of people in the field,
I think they just talk about the amounts of like seconds and the, you know, that a person
has lived, pretending that this is a WLARASA, sort of like a zero initialization of a neural
net.
And it's not like, you can look at a lot of animals, like, for example, Zebras, Zebras
get born and they see and they can run.
There's zero trained data in their life span, they can just do that.
So somehow I have no idea how evolution has found a way to encode these algorithms and
these neural net initializations that are extremely good into ATCGs and I have no idea
how this works, but apparently it's possible because here's a proof by existence.
There's something magical about going from a single cell to an organism that is born
to the first few years of life.
I kind of like the idea that the reason we don't remember anything about the first few
years of our life is that it's a really painful process.
Like it's a very difficult challenging training process.
Yeah.
Like intellectually.
Like.
And maybe, yeah, why don't we remember any of that?
There might be some crazy training going on and maybe that's the background model training
that is very painful.
And so it's best for the system once it's trained not to remember how it's constructed.
I think it's just like the hardware for long-term memory is just not fully developed.
Sure.
The first few years of infants is not actually like learning.
It's brain maturing.
Yeah.
We're born premature.
There's a theory along those lines because of the birth canal and this, along the brain.
And so we're born premature and then the first few years we're just the brain's maturing.
And then there's some learning eventually.
That's my current view on it.
What do you think neural nets can have long-term memory, like that approach is something
like humans?
Do you think there needs to be another meta-architecture on top of it to add something like a knowledge
base that learns facts about the world and all that kind of stuff?
Yes, but I don't know to what extent it will be explicitly constructed.
It might take unintuitive forms where you are telling the GPT, like, you have a declarative
memory bank to which you can store and retrieve data from.
And whenever you encounter some information that you find useful, just save it to your
memory bank.
And here's an example of something you have retrieved and how you say it.
And here's how you load from it.
You just say load whatever you teach it in text in English.
And then it might learn to use a memory bank from that.
Oh, so the neural net is the architecture for the background model, the base thing and
then everything else is just on top of it.
It's not just text, right?
It's, you're giving it gadgets and gizmos.
So you're teaching some kind of a special language by which it can save arbitrary information
and retrieve it at a later time.
And you're telling about these special tokens and how to arrange them to use these interfaces.
And it's like, hey, you can use a calculator.
Here's how you use it.
Just do 5, 3 plus 4, 1 equals.
And when equals is there, a calculator will actually read out the answer and you don't
have to calculate it yourself.
And you just like tell it in English.
This might actually work.
Do you think, in that sense, God was interesting, the deep mind system that it's not just
in the language, but actually throws it all in the same pile, images, actions, all that
kind of stuff.
That's basically what we're moving towards.
Yeah, I think so.
So Goddo is very much a kitchen sink of approach to like reinforcement learning lots of different
environments with a single fixed transformer model, right?
I think it's a very sort of early result in that realm.
But I think, yeah, it's along the lines of what I think things will eventually look
like.
So this is the early days of a system that eventually will look like this, like from a
rich side in perspective.
Yeah, I'm not super huge fan of, I think, all these interfaces that look very different.
I would want everything to be normalized into the same API.
So for example, screen pixels, very same API, instead of having like different world environments
that are very different physics and joint configurations and appearances and whatever.
And you're having some kind of special tokens for different games that you can plug.
I'd rather just normalize everything to a single interface.
So it looks the same to the neural lot.
If that makes sense.
So it's all going to be pixel-based pong in the end.
I think so.
Okay, let me ask you about your own personal life.
A lot of people want to know you're one of the most productive and brilliant people in
the history of AI.
What does a productive day in the life of Andre Kapati look like?
What time do you wake up?
You should look.
Because imagine some kind of dance between the average productive day and a perfect productive
day.
A productive day is the thing we strive towards in the average is kind of what it converges
to.
And all the mistakes and human eventualities and so on.
So what times you wake up?
Are you a morning person?
I'm not a morning person.
I'm a night owl for sure.
Is it stable or not?
It's semi-stable like eight or nine or something like that.
During my PhD, it was even later.
I used to go to sleep usually at 3 a.m.
I think the a.m. hours are precious and very interesting time to work because everyone
has a sleep.
At 8 a.m. or 7 a.m., the east coast is awake.
So there's already activity.
There's already some text messages, whatever.
There's stuff happening.
You can go on like some news website and there's stuff happening and distracting.
At 3 a.m., everything is totally quiet.
And so you're not going to be bothered and you have solid chunks of time to do work.
So I like those periods, night owl by default.
And then I think like productive time, basically, what I like to do is you need to like build
some momentum on the problem without too much distraction.
And you need to load your RAM, your working memory with that problem.
And then you need to be obsessed with it when you're taking shower, when you're falling
asleep.
You need to be obsessed with the problem and it's fully in your memory and you're ready
to wake up and work on it right there.
So it is a skill of, is this in a scale, temporal scale of a single day or a couple of
days a week or a month?
So I can't talk about one day basically in isolation because it's a whole process
when I want to get, when I want to get productive in the problem, I feel like I need a span
of a few days where I can really get in on that problem and I don't want to be interrupted
and I'm going to just be completely obsessed with that problem.
And that's where I do most of my good workouts.
You've done a bunch of cool like little projects in a very short amount of time, very quickly.
So that requires you just focusing on it.
Yeah, basically, I need to load my working memory with the problem and I need to be productive
because there's always like a huge fixed cost to approaching any problem.
I was struggling with this, for example, at Tesla because I want to work on a small
side project.
But okay, you first need to figure out, okay, I need to SSH into my cluster.
I need to bring up a VS code editor so I can work on this.
I need to, I run into some stupid error because of some reason.
You're not at a point where you can be just productive right away.
You are facing barriers.
And so it's about really removing all that barrier and you're able to go into the problem
and you have the full problem loaded in your memory.
And somehow avoiding distractions of all different forms, like news stories, emails, but also
distractions from other interesting projects that you previously worked out, are currently
working on and so on.
You just want to really focus your mind.
And I mean, I can take some time off for distractions and in between, but I think it can't
be too much.
You know, most of your day is sort of like spent on that problem.
And then, you know, I drink coffee, I have my morning routine, I look at some news, Twitter,
hacker news, Wall Street Journal, etc.
So you wake up, you have some coffee, are you trying to get to work as quickly as possible?
Do you take in this diet of like what the hell is happening in the world first?
I am, I do find it interesting to know about the world.
I don't know that it's useful or good, but it is part of my routine right now.
So I do read through a bunch of news articles and I want to be informed and I'm suspicious
of it.
I'm suspicious of the practice, but currently that's where I am.
Oh, you mean suspicious about the positive effect of that practice on your productivity
and your well-being is my well-being psychologically.
And also on your ability to deeply understand the world because there's a bunch of sources
of information.
You're not really focused on deeply integrating it.
That's loaded distracting, you're in terms of a perfectly productive day.
Or how long of a stretch of time in one session do you try to work and focus on a thing?
A couple hours, there's one hours at 30 minutes, there's 10 minutes.
I can probably go like a small few hours and then I need some breaks in between for like
food and stuff.
And yeah, but I think like it's still really hard to accumulate hours.
I was using a tracker that told me exactly how much time I spent coding any one day.
And even on a very productive day, I still spent only like six or eight hours.
And it's just because there's so much padding, commute, talking to people, food, et cetera.
There's like a cost of life just living and sustaining and homeostasis and just maintaining
yourself as a human is very high.
And there seems to be a desire within the human mind to participate in society that creates
that padding.
Yeah.
Yeah, the most productive days I've ever had is just completely from start to finish is
tuning out everything.
Yeah.
Just sitting there and then you could do more than six and eight hours.
Is there some wisdom about what gives you strength to do like tough days of long focus?
Yeah, just like whenever I get obsessed about a problem, something just needs to work,
something just needs to exist.
It needs to exist and you're so you're able to deal with bugs and programming issues and
technical issues and design decisions that turn out to be the wrong ones, you're able
to think through all of that given that you want to think to exist.
Yeah, it needs to exist.
And then I think to me also a big factor is, you know, our other humans are going to
appreciate it.
Are they going to like it?
That's a big part of my motivation.
If I'm helping humans and they seem happy, they say nice things, they tweet about it
or whatever.
That gives me pleasure because I'm doing something useful.
So like you do see yourself sharing it with the world, like with San GitHub, with the blog
posts or videos.
Yeah, I was thinking about it.
Like, suppose I did all these things but did not share them.
I don't think I would have the same motivation that I can build up.
You enjoy the feeling of other people gaining value and happiness from the stuff you've
created.
Yeah.
What about diet?
Is there, I saw you play it in a minute fast, and you fast?
Is that help?
With everything.
With the things you played was been most beneficial to your ability to mentally focus
on a thing and just mental mental productivity and happiness.
You still fast?
Yeah, I still fast but I do intermittent fasting but really what it means at the end of
the day is I skip breakfast.
So I do 18-6 roughly by default when I'm in my steady state.
If I'm traveling or doing something else, I will break the rules but in my steady state
I do 18-6 so I eat only from 12 to 6.
Not a hard rule and I break it often but that's my default.
And then, yeah, I've done a bunch of random experiments for the most part right now where
I've been for the last year and a half I want to say is I'm plant-based or plant-forward.
I heard plant-forward.
It sounds better.
I didn't actually know the differences but it sounds better in my mind.
But it just means I prefer plant-based food and raw or cooked and plant-based.
So plant-based, forgive me, I don't actually know how wide the category of plant entails.
Well, plant-based just means that you're not a little chirped about it and you can flex.
And you just prefer to eat plants and you know you're not trying to influence other people
and if someone is, you come to someone's house party and they serve you a steak that they're
really proud of, you will eat it.
Yes.
It's just like-
That's beautiful.
I mean, that's, I'm the flip side of that but I'm very sort of flexible.
Have you tried doing one meal a day?
I have accidentally, not consistently, but I've accidentally had that.
I don't like it.
I think it makes me feel not good.
It's too much of a hit.
And so currently I have about two meals a day, 12 and 6.
I do that now and stop from doing it now until one meal a day.
Okay.
It's an interesting feeling.
Have you ever fasted longer than a day?
Yeah.
I've done a bunch of water fasts because I'm curious what happens.
What?
Anything interesting.
Yeah, I would say so.
I mean, you know what's interesting is that you're hungry for two days and then starting
day three or so, you're not hungry.
It's like such a weird feeling because you haven't eaten in a few days and you're not
hungry.
Isn't that weird?
It's only one of the many weird things about human biology.
Yeah.
You figure something out.
And finds another source of energy or something like that or relaxes the system.
I don't know how to work.
Yeah.
The body is like, you're hungry, you're hungry.
And then it just gives up.
It's like, okay, I guess we're fasting now.
There's nothing.
And then it's just kind of like focuses on trying to make you not hungry and you know,
not feel the damage of that and trying to give you some space to figure out the food
situation.
So are you still to this day most productive at night?
I would say I am, but it is really hard to maintain my PhD schedule, especially when I
was, say, working at Tesla and so on, it's a non-starter.
So, but even now, like, you know, people want to meet for various events.
They, society lives in a certain period of time and you sort of have to like work.
So that's, it's hard to like do a social thing and then after that, return and do work.
Yeah.
It's just really hard.
That's why I try to do social thing.
That's why I'm not to do too much drinking so I can return and continue doing work.
But a Tesla is there, is there conversions, like Tesla, but any company, is there converges
to almost a schedule or is there more, is that how humans behave when they collaborate?
I need to learn about this.
Yeah.
They try to keep a consistent schedule where you're all awake at the same time.
I'm going to do try to create a routine and I try to create a steady state in which I'm
comfortable in.
So I have a morning routine.
I have a day routine.
I try to keep things to a steady state and things are predictable and then you can sort
of just like your body just sort of like sticks to that.
And if you try to stress that a little too much, it will create, you know, when you're
traveling and you're dealing with jet lag, you're not able to really ascend to, you know,
where you need to go.
Yeah.
We do a lot of humans with the habits and stuff.
What are your thoughts on work life balance throughout a human lifetime?
So testing part was known for sort of pushing people to their limits in terms of what they're
able to do, in terms of what they're trying to do, in terms of how much they work, all
that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
I mean, I will say test like it's all too much bad rep for this because what's happening
is test lies, it's a burst environment.
So I would say the baseline, my only point of reference is Google where I've interned
three times and I saw what it's like inside Google and deep mind.
I would say the baseline is higher than that, but then there's a punctually equilibrium
where once in a while, there's a fire and someone like people work really hard.
And so it's spiky and bursty and then all the stories get collected about the bursts.
And then it gives the appearance of like total insanity, but actually it's just a bit
more intense environment and there are fires and sprints.
And so I think, you know, definitely though, I would say it's a more intense environment
than something you would get.
But in your person, forget all of that, just in your own personal life, what do you think
about the happiness of a human being, a brilliant person like yourself about finding a balance
between work and life, or is it such a thing, not a good thought experiment?
Yeah, I think balance is good, but I also love to have sprints that are out of distribution.
And that's when I think I've been pretty creative as well.
Sprints out of distribution means that most of the time, you have a, yeah, quote unquote,
balance.
I have balance most of the time.
And I like being obsessed with something once in a while.
Once in a while is what?
Once a week, once a month, once a year?
Yeah, probably like say once a month or something, yeah.
And that's when we get, and you get hub repo for my, yeah, that's when you're like really
care about a problem.
It must exist.
It's awesome, you're obsessed with it, and now you can't just do it on that day.
You need to pay the fixed cost of getting into the groove, and then you need to stay there
for a while.
And then society will come, and they will try to mess with you, and they will try to distract
you.
Yeah, the worst thing is like a person who's like, I just need five minutes of your time.
Yeah.
This is the cost of that is not five minutes.
And society needs to change how it thinks about just five minutes of your time.
Right.
It's never, it's never.
Just one minute.
It's just 30.
It's just a quick thing.
Yeah.
No.
What's your computer setup?
What's like the perfect, do you, are you somebody that's flexible to no matter what, laptop,
four screens?
Yeah.
Or do you prefer a certain setup that you're most productive?
I guess the one that I'm familiar with is one large screen, 27 inch, and my laptop
on the side.
What operating system?
I do max.
That's my primary.
For all tasks.
I would say OSX.
But when you're working on deep learning, everything is Linux, your SSH into a cluster
and you're working remotely.
But what about the actual development like that using the IDE?
Yeah, you would use, I think a good way is you just run VS code.
My favorite error right now on your Mac, but you are actually, you have a remote folder
through SSH.
So the actual files that you're manipulating are on the cluster somewhere else.
So what's the best IDE?
VS code, what else do people, so I use EMAX still, it may be cool, I don't know if it's
maximum productivity.
So what do you recommend in terms of editors, you worked a lot of software engineers, editors
for Python, C++ machine learning applications?
I think the current answer is VS code.
Currently I believe that's the best IDE.
It's got a huge amount of extensions, it has GitHub co-pilot integration, which I think
is very valuable.
What do you think about the co-pilot integration?
I was actually, I got to talk a bunch with Guido and Rasm was the creative Python and he
loves co-pilot, he like, he programs a lot with it.
Do you?
Yeah, use co-pilot, I love it and it's free for me, but I would pay for it.
Yeah, I think it's very good and the utility that I found with it was, I would say there
is a learning curve and you need to figure out when it's helpful and when to pay attention
to its outputs and when it's not going to be helpful, where you should not pay attention
to it.
Because if you're just reading at suggestions all the time, it's not a good way of interacting
with it.
But I think I was able to sort of mold myself to it.
I find it's very helpful, number one, in copy paste and replace some parts.
So I don't, when the pattern is clear, it's really good at completing the pattern.
And number two, sometimes it suggests APIs that I'm not aware of.
So it tells you about something that you didn't know.
And that's an opportunity to discover and use it.
It's an opportunity too.
So I would never take co-pilot code as given.
I almost always copy a copy paste into a Google search and you see what this function is
doing.
And then you're like, oh, it's actually exactly what I need.
Thank you, co-pilot.
So you learned something.
So it's in part of search engine, part, maybe getting the exact syntax correctly that
once you see it, it's that NP-hard thing is that once you see it, you know, it's correct.
Exactly.
It's very helpful, you can verify efficiently, but you can't generate efficiently.
And co-pilot really, I mean, it's autopilot for programming, right?
And currently is doing the link following, which is like the simple copy paste and sometimes
suggest.
But over time, it's going to become more and more autonomous.
And so the same thing will play out in not just coding, but actually across many, many
different things probably.
But coding is an important one, right?
Writing programs.
Yeah.
How do you see the future of that developing the program synthesis, like being able to
write programs that are more and more complicated?
Because right now, it's human supervised in interesting ways.
Yes.
It feels like the transition will be very painful.
My mental model for it is the same thing will happen to us with the autopilot.
So currently is doing the link following, is doing some simple stuff.
And eventually we'll be doing autonomy, and people will have to intervene less and less.
And there could be like testing mechanisms, like if it writes a function, and that function
looks pretty damn correct, but how do you know it's correct?
Because you're like getting lazier and lazier as a programmer, like your ability to,
because like little bugs, but I guess it won't make little mistakes.
No, it will.
It copilot will make off by one subtle bugs.
It has done that to me.
But do you think future systems will, or is it really the off by one is actually a fundamental
challenge of programming?
In that case, it wasn't fundamental, and I think things can improve.
But yeah, I think humans have to supervise.
I am nervous about people not supervising what comes out.
And what happens to, for example, the proliferation of bugs in all of our systems.
I'm nervous about that.
But I think there will probably be some other copilots for bug finding and stuff like that
at some point.
There will be like a lot more automation for a man.
So it's like a program, a copilot that generates a compiler, one that does a linter, one that
does like a type checker.
Yeah.
It's a committee of like a GPT sort of like, and then there will be like a manager for
the committee.
Yeah.
And then there will be somebody that says a new version of this is needed.
We need to regenerate it.
Yeah.
There were 10 GPT's.
They were forwarded and gave 50 suggestions.
Another one looked at it and picked a few that they like, a bug one looked at it and it
was like, it's probably a bug.
They got re-ranked by some other thing.
And then a final ensemble GPT comes in and it's like, okay, given everything you guys
have told me, this is probably the next token.
You know, the feeling is the number of programmers in the world has been growing and growing very
quickly.
Do you think it's possible that it'll actually level out and drop to like a very low
number with this kind of world?
Because then you'll be doing software 2.0 programming and you'll be doing this kind
of generation of copilot type systems programming, but you won't be doing the old school software
1.0 programming.
I don't currently think that they're just going to replace you in programmers.
I'm so hesitant saying stuff like this, because this is going to be replacing five years.
I mean, no, it's going to show that, like, this is where we thought, because I agree
with you, but I think it might be very surprised, right?
Like, what are the next, what's your sense of where we stand with language models?
Like, does it feel like the beginning or the middle or the end?
The beginning.
And I think the big question in my mind is, for sure, GPT will be able to program quite
well, competently and so on.
How do you steer the system?
You still have to provide some guidance to what you actually are looking for.
And so how do you steer it and how do you say, how do you talk to it?
How do you audit it and verify that what is done is correct?
And how do you work with this?
And it's as much, not just an AI problem, but a UI UX problem.
So beautiful fertile ground for so much interesting work for VS Code Plus Plus, where you're not
just this not just human programming anymore.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
So you're interacting with the system.
So not just one prompt, but it iterative prompting, you're trying to figure out having
a conversation with the system.
Yeah.
That actually, I mean, to me, that's super exciting to have a conversation with the program
I'm writing.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe at some point, you're just conversing with it.
It's like, okay, here's what I want to do.
Maybe this variable, maybe it's not even that low level as variable, but you can also
imagine, like, can you translate this to C++ and back to Python and back to it?
Yeah, I know.
Already kind of existence.
No, but just like doing it as part of the program experience, like, I think I'd like
to write this function in C++ or like, you just keep changing for different, different
programs because of different syntax.
Maybe I want to convert this into a functional language.
Yeah.
I mean, you get to become multilingual as a programmer and dance back and forth efficiently.
I mean, I think the UI, UX, a fit though, is like, still very hard to think through because
it's not just about writing code on a page.
You have an entire developer environment.
You have a bunch of hardware on it.
You have some environmental variables.
You have some scripts that are running in the Chrome job, like, there's a lot going
on to, like, working with computers and how do these systems set up environment flags
and work across multiple machines and set up screen sessions and automate different
processes like how all that works and is auditable by humans and so on is like massive
question to a moment.
You've built archive sanity.
What is archive and what is the future of academic research publishing that you would
like to see?
So archive is this pre-print server.
So if you have a paper, you can submit it for publication to journals or conferences
and then wait six months and then maybe get a decision, pass or fail, or you can just
upload it to archive and then people can tweet about it three minutes later.
And then everyone sees it.
Everyone reads it and everyone can profit from it in their own way.
You can cite it and it has an official look to it.
It feels like a publication process.
It feels different if you just put it in a blog post.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, it's a paper and usually the bar is higher for something that you would
expect on archive as opposed to something you would see in a blog post.
So the culture created the bar because you could probably host a pretty crappy fix or an
archive.
So what does that make you feel like?
What does that make you feel about peer review?
So rigorous peer review by two, three experts versus the peer review of the community right
as it's written.
Yeah.
Basically, I think the community is very well able to peer review things very quickly on
Twitter.
And I think maybe it just has to do something with AI machine learning field specifically
though.
I feel like things are more easily auditable and the verification is easier potentially than
the verification somewhere else.
So it's kind of like you can think of these scientific publications as like little blockchains
where everyone's building on each other's work and setting each other.
And you sort of have AI, which is kind of like this much faster and loose blockchain.
But then you have and any one individual entry is like very, very cheap to make.
And then you have other fields where maybe that model doesn't make as much sense.
And so I think in AI, at least things are pretty easily very viable.
And so that's why when people upload papers, they're a really good idea on someone.
People can try it out like the next day.
And they can be the final arbiter of whether it works or not on their problem.
And the whole thing just moves significantly faster.
So I kind of feel like academia still has a place.
So this like conference journal process still has a place.
But it's sort of like an it lacks behind, I think.
And it's a bit more maybe higher quality process.
But it's not sort of the place where you will discover cutting edge work anymore.
It used to be the case when I was starting my PhD that you go to conferences and journals
and you discuss all the latest research.
Now when you go to a conference or a journal like no one discusses anything that's there
because it's already like three generations ago irrelevant.
Yeah.
Which makes me sad about like deep mind, for example, where they still publish in nature
and these big prestigious, I mean, there's still value, I suppose, of the prestige that
comes with these big venues.
But the result is that they will announce and break through performance and it will
take like a year to actually publish the details.
I mean, and those details, if they were published immediately, wouldn't inspire the community
to move in certain directions.
Yeah.
Let's speed up the rest of the community.
But I don't know to what extent that's part of their objective function also.
That's true.
So it's not just the prestige a little bit of the delay is part.
Yeah, they certainly deep mind specifically has been working in the regime of having slightly
higher quality, basically process and latency and publishing those papers that way.
Another question from Reddit.
Do you or have you suffered from imposter syndrome?
Being the director of AI Tesla, being this person when you're a Stanford where like the
world looks at you as the expert in AI to teach the world about machine learning.
When I was leaving Tesla after five years, I spent a ton of time in meeting rooms.
And I would read papers in the beginning when I joined Tesla, I was writing code and
then I was writing less and less code and I was reading code and then I was reading less
and less code.
And so this is just a natural progression that happens, I think.
And definitely I would say near the tail end, that's when it sort of like starts to hit
you a bit more that you're supposed to be an expert, but actually the source of truth
is the code that people are writing the GitHub and the actual code itself.
And you're not as familiar with that as you used to be.
And so I would say maybe there's some like insecurity there.
Yeah, that's actually pretty profound.
That a lot of the insecurity has to do with not writing the code in the computer science
space.
Like that because that is the truth that they're right there.
The code is the source of truth, the papers and everything else.
It's a high level summary.
I don't, yeah, just a high level summary, but at the end of the day, you have to read
code.
It's impossible to translate all that code into actual, you know, paper form.
So when things come out, especially when they have a source code available, that's my
favorite place to go.
So like I said, you're one of the greatest teachers of machine learning AI ever from CS
to 31N to today.
What advice would you give to beginners interested in getting into machine learning?
Beginners are often focused on like what to do.
And I think the focus should be more like how much you do.
So I am kind of like believer on the high level and this 10,000 hours kind of concept
where you just kind of have to just pick the things where you can spend time and you
care about and you're interested in.
You literally have to put in 10,000 hours of work.
It doesn't even like matter as much like where you put it and you'll iterate and you'll
improve and you'll waste some time.
I don't know if there's a better way.
You need to put in 10,000 hours.
But I think it's actually really nice because I feel like there's some sense of determinism
about being an expert at a thing if you spend 10,000 hours.
You can literally pick an arbitrary thing and I think if you spend 10,000 hours of deliberate
effort and work, you actually will become an expert at it.
And so I think it's kind of like a nice thought and so basically I would focus more on like
are you spending 10,000 hours?
That's what I focus on.
So and then thinking about what kind of mechanisms maximize your likelihood of getting
to 10,000 hours.
Yes.
Exactly.
Which for us silly humans means probably forming a daily habit of like every single day
actually doing the thing.
Whatever helps you.
So I do think to a large extent is a psychological problem for yourself.
One other thing that I help that I think is helpful for the psychology of it is many
times people compare themselves to others in the area.
I think it's very harmful.
Only compare yourself to you from some time ago, like say a year ago, are you better than
you year ago?
It's the only way to think.
And I think this then you can see your progress and it's very motivating.
That's so interesting that focus on the quantity of hours because I think a lot of people
in the beginner stage, but actually throughout, get paralyzed by the choice.
Like which one do I pick this path or this path?
Yeah.
Like they'll literally get paralyzed by like which ID to use.
Well, they're worried.
Yeah, they'll worry about all these things.
But the thing is some of the you will waste time doing something wrong.
Yes.
You will eventually figure out it's not right.
You will accumulate scar tissue.
And next time you'll grow stronger because next time you'll have the scar tissue and next
time you'll learn from it.
And next time you come to a similar situation, you'll be like, I messed up.
I've spent a lot of time working on things that never materialize into anything.
And I have a scar tissue and I have some intuitions about what wasn't useful, how things
turned out.
So all those mistakes where we're not dead work.
So I just think, did you just focus on working?
What have you done?
What have you done last week?
That's a good question actually to ask for a lot of things that just machine learning.
It's a good way to cut the, the way I forgot what the term we used, but the fluff, the
blubber, whatever the inefficiencies in life.
What do you love about teaching?
You seem to find yourself often drawn to teaching.
You're very good at it, but you're also drawn to it.
I mean, I don't think I love teaching.
I love happy humans and happy humans like when I teach.
I wouldn't say I hate teaching, I tolerate teaching, but it's not like the act of teaching
that I like.
It's that I have something, I'm actually okay at it, I'm okay at teaching and people
appreciate it a lot.
And so I'm just happy to try to be helpful.
And teaching itself is not like the most, I mean, it's really, it can be really annoying
frustrating.
I was working on a bunch of lectures just now.
I was reminded back to my days of 231 and just how much work it is to create some of
these materials and make them good, the amount of iteration and thought and you go down
blind alleys and just how much you change it.
So creating something good in terms of like educational values is really hard and it's
not fun.
It was difficult.
So for people to definitely go watch your new stuff, you put out their lectures, we actually
building the thing like from like you said, the code is truth.
So discussing back propagation by building it, by looking through and just the whole thing.
So how difficult is that to prepare for?
I think it's a really powerful way to teach how, did you have to prepare for that or are
you just live thinking through it?
I will typically do like say three takes and then I take like the better take.
So I do multiple takes and then I take some of the better takes and then I just build
that lecture that way.
Sometimes I have to delete 30 minutes of content because it just went down the alley that
I didn't like too much.
There's a bunch of iteration and it probably takes me, you know, somewhere around 10 hours
to create one hour of content to do one hour.
It's interesting.
I mean, is it difficult to go back to the like the basics?
Do you draw a lot of like wisdom from going back to the basics?
Yeah, going back to back propagation lost functions where they come from.
And one thing I like about teaching a lot honestly is it definitely strengthens your understanding.
So it's not a purely altruistic activity.
It's a way to learn.
If you have to explain something to someone, you realize you have gaps in knowledge.
And so I even surprised myself in those lectures like, well, the result will obviously look
at this and then the result doesn't look like it and I'm like, okay, I thought I understood
this.
Yeah.
So that's why it's really cool to literally code you run it in a notebook and it gives
you a result.
And you're like, oh, wow, and like actual numbers, actual input, actual, you know, actual
code.
Yeah, it's not mathematical symbols, etc.
The source of truth is the code.
It's not slides.
It's just like, let's build it.
It's beautiful.
You're a rare human in that sense.
What advice would you give to researchers trying to develop and publish idea that have a
big impact in the world of AI, so maybe undergrads, maybe early graduate students?
Yeah.
I mean, I would say like they definitely have to be a little bit more strategic than I
had to be as a PhD student because of the way AI is evolving.
It's going the way of physics where, you know, in physics, you used to be able to do experiments
on your bench top and everything was great and you could make progress.
And now you have to work in like LHC or like CERN.
And so AI is going in that direction as well.
So there's certain kinds of things that's just not possible to do on the bench top anymore.
And I think that didn't used to be the case at the time.
Do you still think that there's like GAN type papers to be written or like a very simple
idea that requires just one computer to illustrate a simple example?
I mean, one example that's been very influential recently is diffusion models.
The fusion models are amazing.
The fusion models are six years old for the longest time people who are kind of ignoring them
as far as I can tell.
And they're an amazing generative model, especially in images.
And so stable diffusion and so on.
It's all the fusion based.
The fusion is new.
It was not there and came from, well, it came from Google, but a researcher could have
come up with it.
In fact, some of the first, actually, no, those came from Google as well.
But a researcher could come up with that in an academic institution.
Yeah.
What do you find most fascinating about diffusion models?
So from the societal impact of the technical architecture.
What I like about diffusion is it works so well.
Is that surprising to you?
The amount of the variety, almost the novelty of the synthetic data is generating.
Yes.
So the stable diffusion images are incredible.
It's the speed of improvement in generating images has been insane.
We went very quickly from generating like tiny digits to tiny faces and it all looked
messed up and now we have a stable diffusion.
And that happened very quickly.
There's a lot that academia can still contribute.
You know, for example, flash attention is a very efficient kernel for running the attention
operation inside the transformer that came from academic environment.
It's a very clever way to structure the kernel that does the calculation, so it doesn't
materialize the attention matrix.
And so there's, I think there's still lots of things to contribute, but you have to be
just more strategic.
Do you think neural networks can be made to reason?
Yes.
Do you think they're already reason?
What's your definition of reasoning?
Information processing.
So in the way the humans think through a problem and come up with novel ideas, it feels
like reasoning.
Yeah.
So the novelty, I don't want to say, but out of distribution ideas, you think it's possible?
Yes.
I think we're seeing that already in the current neural nets.
You're able to remix the training set information into true generalization in some sense.
That doesn't appear.
It doesn't appear in the training set.
Like you're doing something interesting algorithmically.
You're manipulating some symbols and you're coming up with some correct unique answer
in a new setting.
What would illustrate to you, holy shit, this thing is definitely thinking?
To me, thinking or reasoning is just information processing and generalization.
I think the neural nets already do that today.
So being able to perceive the world or perceive whatever the inputs are and to make predictions
based on that or actions based on that, that's the reason.
Yeah.
You're giving correct answers in novel settings by manipulating information.
You've learned the correct algorithm.
You're not doing just some kind of a lookup table on the Earth's neighbor search.
Let me ask you about AGI.
What are some moonshirt ideas you think might make significant progress towards AGI?
Maybe another way is what are the big blockers that we're missing now.
So basically, I am fairly bullish on our ability to build AGI's.
Basically automated systems that we can interact with and are very human-like and we can interact
with them in a digital realm or a physical realm.
Currently, it seems most of the models that do these magical tasks are in a text realm.
I think, as I mentioned, I'm suspicious that the text realm is not enough to actually
build full understanding of the world.
I do actually think you need to go into pixels and understand the physical world and how
it works.
So I do think that we need to extend these models to consume images and videos and train
on a lot more data that is multimodal in that way.
Do you think you need to touch the world to understand it also?
Well, that's the big open question, I would say, in my mind.
If you also require the embodiment and the ability to interact with the world, run experiments
and have a data of that form, then you need to go to Optimus or something like that.
So I would say Optimus in some way is like a hedge in AGI because it seems to me that
it's possible that just having data from the internet is not enough.
If that is the case, then Optimus may lead to AGI because Optimus, to me, there's nothing
beyond Optimus.
You have this humanoid form factor that can actually do stuff in the world.
You can have millions of them interacting with humans and so on.
And if that doesn't give rise to AGI, at some point, I'm not sure what will.
So from a completeness perspective, I think that's the really good platform.
But it's a much harder platform because you are dealing with atoms and you need to actually
like build these things and integrate them into society.
So I think that path takes longer, but it's much more certain.
And then there's a path of the internet and just like training these compression models
effectively on trying to compress all the internet.
And that might also give these agents as well.
Compress the internet but also interact with the internet.
Yeah.
So it's not obvious to me, in fact, I suspect you can reach AGI without ever entering
the physical world.
And which is a little bit more concerning because that results in it happening faster.
So it just feels like we're in boiling water.
We won't know as it's happening.
I would like to, I'm not afraid of AGI.
I'm excited about it.
There's always concerns, but I would like to know when it happens and have hints about
when it happens.
Like a year from now, it will happen, that kind of thing.
Yeah.
I just feel like in the digital realm, it just might happen.
I think all we have available to us because no one has built AGI again.
So all we have available to us is, is there enough fertile ground on the periphery?
I would say yes.
And we have the progress so far, which has been very rapid.
And there are next steps that are available.
And so I would say, yeah, it's quite likely that will be interacting with digital entities.
How do you know that we, somebody has built AGI?
It's going to be a slow, I think it's going to be a slow incremental transition.
It's going to be product based and focused.
It's going to be GitHub Copial getting better.
And then GPT's helping you write.
And then these oracles that you can go to with mathematical problems.
I think we're on a, on a verge of being able to ask very complex questions in chemistry,
physics, math of these oracles and have them complete solutions.
So AGI to use primarily focused on intelligence.
So consciousness doesn't enter into it.
So in my mind, consciousness is not a special thing.
You will, you will figure out and bolt on.
I think it's an emergent phenomenon of a large enough and complex enough generative model
sort of.
So if you have a complex enough world model that understands the world, then it also understands
its predicament in the world as being a language model, which to me is a form of consciousness
or self-awareness.
In order to understand the world deeply, you probably have to integrate yourself into
the world.
Yeah.
In order to interact with humans and other living beings, consciousness is a very useful
tool.
Yeah.
I think consciousness is like a modeling insight.
Modeling insight.
Yeah.
It's a, you have a powerful enough model of understanding the world that you actually understand
that you are an entity in it.
Yeah, but there's also this, perhaps just a narrative we tell ourselves, there's a,
it feels like something to experience the world, the hard problem of consciousness.
Yeah.
But that could be just an narrative that we tell ourselves.
Yeah, I don't think, well, yeah, I think it will emerge.
I think it's going to be something very boring.
Like, we'll be talking to these digital AI, they will claim their conscious.
They will appear conscious.
They will do all the things that you would expect of other humans and it's going to just
be a stalemate.
I, I think there would be a lot of actual fascinating ethical questions, like Supreme
Court level questions of whether you're allowed to turn off a conscious AI.
If you're allowed to build the conscious AI, maybe there would have to be the same kind
of the base that you have around, sorry, to bring up a political topic, but, you know,
a portion, which is the deeper question with abortion is what is life?
And the deep question with AI is also what is life and what is conscious.
And I think they'll be very fascinating to bring up.
It might become illegal to build systems that are capable of such level of intelligence
that consciousness would emerge and therefore the capacity to suffer would emerge.
And a system that says, no, please don't kill me.
Well, that's what the Lambda, the Lambda chatbot already told the school engineer, right?
Like it was talking about not wanting to die or so on.
So that might become illegal to do that, right?
Right.
Because otherwise you might have a lot of, a lot of creatures that don't want to die and
they will, you can just spawn and penetrate someone cluster.
And then that might lead to like horrible consequences, because then there might be a lot
of people that secretly love murder and they'll start practicing murder and those systems.
I mean, there's just, to me, all of this stuff just brings a beautiful mirror to the human
condition and human nature and we'll get to explore it.
And that's what like the best of the Supreme Court of all the different debates we have
about ideas of what it means to be human.
We get to ask those deep questions that would be asking throughout human history.
There has always been the other in human history where the good guys and that's the bad guys
and we're going to, you know, throughout human history, let's murder the bad guys.
And the same will probably happen with robots, so it'll be the other at first and then we'll
get to ask questions.
So what does it mean to be alive?
What does it mean to be conscious?
Yeah.
And I think there's some canary in a coal mine, even with what we have today.
And you know, like for example, these, there's these like wifews that you get like work
with and some people are trying to like, this company is going to shut down, but this
person really like, yeah, love their waifu and like, it's trying to like, port it somewhere
else and like, it's not possible and like, I think like definitely people will have feelings
towards, towards these systems because in some sense, they are like a mirror of humanity
because they are like sort of like a big average of humanity in a way that it's trained.
But we can, that average, we can actually watch.
It's nice to be able to interact with the big average of humanity and do like a search
query on it.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's very fascinating.
And we can also, of course, also like shape it.
It's not just a pure average, we can mess with the training data, we can mess with the
objective, we can fine-tune them in various ways.
So we have some, you know, impact on what those systems look like.
If you want to achieve AGI and you could have a conversation with her and ask her, talk
about anything, maybe ask her a question, what kind of stuff would you, would you ask?
I would have some practical questions on my mind like, do I or my loved ones really have
to die?
What can we do about that?
Do you think it will answer clearly or would it answer poetically?
I would expect it to give solutions.
I would expect it to be like, well, I've read all of these textbooks and I know all
these things that you've produced.
And it seems to me like, here are the experiments that I think it would be useful to run next.
And here's some gene therapies that I think would be helpful.
And here are the kinds of experiments that you should run.
Okay.
Let's go with this thought experiment.
That mortality is actually like a prerequisite for happiness.
So if we become immortal, we'll actually become deeply unhappy.
And the model is able to know that.
So what is it supposed to tell you stupid human about it?
Yes, you can become immortal, but you will become deeply unhappy.
If the model is, if the AGI system is trying to empathize with you human, what is it supposed
to tell you?
Say yes, you don't have to die, but you're really not going to like it, because it's going
to be deeply honest.
Like, there's an interstellar.
What is it?
The AGI says, like, humans want 90% honesty.
So like, you have to pick how honest I want to answer these practical questions.
Yeah.
I love AI interstellar, by the way.
I think it's like such a sidekick to the entire story, but at the same time, it's like
really interesting.
It's kind of limited in certain ways, right?
Yeah.
And I think that's totally fine, by the way.
I don't think, I think it's fine and plausible to have a limited and imperfect AGI's.
Is that the feature almost as an example, like it has a fixed mind of compute on its physical
body.
And it might just be that even though you can have a super amazing mega brain, super intelligent
AI, you can also kind of like, you know, less intelligent AI, so you can deploy it in
a power efficient way.
And then they're not perfect.
They might make mistakes.
I meant more like, say you had infinite compute, and it's still good to make mistakes sometimes.
Like, in order to integrate yourself, like, what is it going back to Goodwill Hunting?
Robin Williams character says like the human imperfections, that's good stuff, right?
Isn't it?
Isn't that the, like, we don't want perfect?
We want flaws in part to form connected with each other because it feels like something
you can attach your feelings to the, the flaws in that same way you want AI that's flawed.
I don't know.
I feel like perfectionist.
But then you're saying, okay, yeah, but that's not AGI, but see AGI would need to be intelligent
enough to give answers to humans and understand, and I think perfect isn't something humans
can't understand because even science doesn't give perfect answers.
There's always gabs and mysteries and I don't know, I don't know if humans want
perfect.
Yeah, I can imagine just having a conversation with this kind of oracle entity as you'd
imagine them, and yeah, maybe it can tell you about, you know, based on my analysis
of human condition, you might not want this.
And here are some of the things that might, but every, every dumb human will say, yeah,
yeah, trust me, I can, give me the truth, I can handle it.
But that's the beauty.
Like, people can choose.
So, but then the old marshmallow test with the kids and so on, I feel like too many
people can't handle the truth, probably including myself, like the deep truth of the human
condition.
I don't know if I can handle it.
Like, what if there's some darks that, what if we are an alien science experiment, and
it realizes that, what if it hacked, I mean, I mean, this is the matrix, you know, all
over again.
I don't know, I would, what would I talk about?
I don't even, yeah, I probably I'll go with the safe for scientific questions at first
that have nothing to do with my own personal life, and mortality, just like about physics
and so on, to build up, like, let's see where is that, or maybe see if it has a sense
of humor.
That's another question, would it be able to, presumably in order to, if it understands
humans deeply, would be able to generate, yeah, to generate humor?
Yeah, I think that's actually a wonderful benchmark almost, like, is it able, I think that's
a really good point, basically, to make you laugh.
Yeah, if it's able to be like a very effective stand-up comedian that is doing something very
interesting computationally, I think being funny is extremely hard.
Yeah, because it's hard in a way, like a touring test, the original intent of the touring
test is hard, because you have to convince humans, and there's nothing, that's why, that's
why, I mean, comedians talk about this, like, there's, this is deeply honest, because if
people can't help but laugh, and if they don't laugh, that means you're not funny, if
they laugh, that's funny.
Yeah, that's funny.
And you're showing, you need a lot of knowledge to create, to create humor about, like,
you mentioned human condition and so on, and then you need to be clever with it.
You mentioned a few movies, you tweeted, movies that I've seen five plus times, but I'm
ready and willing to keep watching, interstellar, gladiator, contact, good, we'll hunting the
matrix, load of the rings, all three avatar, fifth element, so on, it goes on.
Terminator 2, mean girls, I'm not going to ask about that, I think, I think girls is great.
What are some of the jump onto your memory that you love, and why, like you mentioned
the matrix, as a computer person, why do you love the matrix?
There's so many properties that make it, like, beautiful, interesting, so there's all
these philosophical questions, but then there's also AGI's, and there's simulation, and
it's cool, and there's, you know, the black, you know, the look of it, the feel of it,
the feel of it, the action, the bullet time, it was just like innovating in so many ways.
And then good, well, good, well hunting way, like that one.
Yeah, I just, I really like this torture genius sort of character who's, like, grappling
with whether or not he has, like, any responsibility or, like, what to do with this gift that he
was given, or like, how to think about the whole thing.
And there's also a dance between the genius and the, the personal, like, what it means
to love another human being, and there's a lot of themes there, it's just a beautiful
movie.
And then the fatherly figure, the mentor in the, in the psychiatrist and the, it like,
really like, it messes with you, you know, there's some movies that's just like, really
mess with you on a deep level.
Do you relate to that movie at all?
No.
It's not your fault.
As I said, Lord of the Rings, that's self-explanatory, Terminator 2, which is interesting.
You rewatch that a lot.
Is that better than Terminator 1?
You like Arnold?
I do like Terminator 1 as well.
I like Terminator 2 a little bit more, but in terms of, like, its surface properties.
Do you think SkyNet is at all a possibility?
Oh, yes.
Like the actual sort of autonomous weapon system kind of thing.
Do you worry about that stuff?
I do worry about it.
A hundred percent.
And so the, I mean, the, you know, some of these fears of AGS and how this will plan
out, I mean, these will be like very powerful entities, probably at some point.
And so for a long time, there are going to be tools in the hands of humans.
You know, people talk about, like, alignment of AGS and how to make, the problem is, like,
even humans are not aligned.
So how this will be used and what this is going to look like is, um, yes, troubling.
So do you think it'll happen slow, slow enough that we'll be able to, as a, as a human
civilization, think through the problems?
Yes.
That's my hope is that it happens slowly enough and, and open enough way where a lot of
people can see and participate in it.
Just figure out how to deal with this transition, I think, which is going to be interesting.
I draw a lot of inspiration from nuclear weapons because I sure thought it would be, it would
be fucked once they develop nuclear weapons, but like, it's almost like, uh, when, uh, when
the systems are not so dangerous, they destroy human civilization, we deploy them and, and
learn the lessons.
And then we quickly, if it's too dangerous, we'll quickly, we might still deploy it, uh,
but you very quickly learn not to use them.
And so there'll be like this balance achieved.
Humans are very clever as a species.
It's interesting.
We exploit the resources as much as we can, but we don't.
We avoid destroying ourselves.
It seems like.
Yeah.
Well, I don't know about that, actually.
I hope it continues.
Um, I mean, I'm definitely like concerned about nuclear weapons and so on, not just as
a result of the recent conflict, even before that, uh, that's probably my number one concern
for society.
So if humanity, uh, destroys itself, or destroys, you know, 90% of people, that would
be because of nukes.
I think so.
Um, and it's not even about full destruction to me.
It's bad enough if we reset society, though, it would be like terrible, it would be really
bad.
And I can't believe we're like so close to it.
Yeah.
It's like so crazy to me.
It feels like we might be a few tweets away from something like that.
Yeah.
Basically, it's extremely unnerving, but it has been for me for a long time.
It seems unstable that world leaders, just having a bad mood can like, um, take one
step towards a bad direction and it escalates.
Yeah.
And because of a collection of bad moods, it can escalate without being able to, um, stop.
It's just a huge amount of power.
And then also with the proliferation, basically, I don't, I don't actually really see, I don't
actually know what the good outcomes are here.
So I'm definitely worried about that a lot.
And then AGI is not currently there, but I think at some point, it will more and more
become something like it, the danger with AGI even is that I think it's even less likely
worse in a sense that there are good outcomes of AGI.
And then the bad outcomes are like an epsilon away, like a tiny one away.
And so I think capitalism and humanity and so on will drive for the positive, uh, ways
of using that technology, but then if bad outcomes are just like a tiny, like flip a
minus sign away, uh, that's a really bad position to be in a tiny perturbation of the system
results in the destruction of the human species.
So we are lying to walk.
Yeah.
I think in general, it was really weird about like the dynamics of humanity and this explosion
was talked about is just like the insane coupling afforded by technology and, uh, just
the instability of the whole dynamical system, I think it's just, it doesn't look good
honestly.
Yes.
So that explosion could be destructive or constructive and the probabilities are non-zero
in both.
Yeah.
I'm going to have to, I do feel like I have to try to be optimistic and so on.
Yes.
In this case, I still am predominantly optimistic, but there's definitely me too.
Uh, do you think we'll become a multi planetary species?
Probably yes, but I don't know if it's dominant feature of, uh, future humanity.
There might be some people on some planets and so on, but I'm not sure if it's like, yeah,
if it's like a major player in our culture and so on, we still have to solve the drivers
of self-destruction here on earth.
So just having a backup on Mars is not going to solve the problem.
So by the way, I love the backup on Mars.
I think that's amazing.
We should absolutely do that.
Yes.
And I'm so thankful.
Would you, uh, would you go to Mars personally, no, I do like earth quite a lot.
Okay.
I'll go to Mars.
I'll go for you.
I'll tweet at you for maybe eventually I would once it's safe enough, but I don't
actually know if it's on my lifetime scale, unless I can extend it by a lot.
I do think that, for example, a lot of people might disappear into, um, virtual realities
and stuff like that.
I think that could be the major thrust of, um, sort of the cultural development of humanity
if it survives.
Uh, so it might not be, it's just really hard to work in physical realm and go out there.
And I think ultimately all your experiences are in your brain.
Yeah.
And so it's much easier to disappear into digital realm.
And I think people will find them more compelling, easier, safer, more interesting.
So you're a little bit captivated by virtual reality by the possible worlds, whether it's
the metaverse or some other manifestation of that.
Yeah.
It's really interesting.
And so, um, I'm interested in just, just talking a lot to Carmack.
Where's the, where's the thing that's currently preventing that?
Yeah.
To be clear, I think what's interesting about the future is, um, it's not that I kind
of feel like the variance in a human condition grows.
It's the primary thing that's changing.
It's not as much demean of the distribution, it's like the variance of it.
So there will probably be people in Mars and there will be people in VR and there will
people here on Earth.
It's just like there will be so many more ways of being.
And so I kind of feel like I see it as like a spreading out of a human experience.
There's something about the internet that allows you to discover those little groups
and you gravitate to something about your biology, likes that kind of world that you find
each other.
Yeah.
And we'll have transhumanists and then we'll have the omnis and they're going to, everything
is just going to coexist.
You know, the cool thing about it because I've interacted with a bunch of internet communities
is, um, they don't know about each other.
Like you can have a very happy existence, just like having a very close neck community
and not knowing about each other.
I mean, even you even sense this just having travel to Ukraine, there's, they, they don't
know so many things about America.
Yeah.
Like, when you travel across the world, I think you experience this too.
There are certain cultures that are like, they have their own thing going on.
They don't.
So you, you can see that happening more and more and more and more in the future.
We have little communities.
Yeah.
I think so.
That seems to be the, that seems to be how it's going right now.
And I don't see that trend, like really reversing.
I think people are diverse and they're able to choose their own, like, path and existence.
And I sort of like celebrate that.
And so we use been something much time in the metaverse in the virtual reality or which
community area.
Are you the physicalist, the, the, the, the physical reality, enjoyer or do you see drawing
a lot of pleasure and fulfillment in the digital world?
Yeah.
I think, well, currently the virtual reality is not that compelling.
I do think it can improve a lot, but I don't really know to what extent.
Maybe, you know, there's actually, like, even more exotic things you can think about
with, like, neural links or stuff like that.
So currently, I kind of see myself as mostly a team human person.
I love nature.
Yeah.
I love harmony.
I love people.
I love humanity.
I love emotions of humanity.
And I, I just want to be like in this, like, solar punk little utopia that's my happy place.
Yes.
My happy place is like people I love thinking about cool problems around by a lush, beautiful,
dynamic nature.
Yeah.
And secretly high tech in places that count places like the use technology to,
to empower that love for other humans and nature.
Yeah.
I think a technology used, like, very sparingly.
I don't love when it sort of gets in the way of humanity in many ways.
I like just people being humans in the way we sort of, like, slightly evolved and prefer
I think just by default.
People kept asking me because they know you love reading.
Are there particular books that you enjoyed that had an impact on you for silly or for
profound reasons that you recommend?
You mentioned the vital question.
Many, of course.
I think in biology as an example, the vital question is a good one.
Anything by Niclaine, really, life ascending, I would say, is like a bit more potentially
representative as like a summary of a lot of the things he's been talking about.
I was very impacted by the selfish gene.
I thought that was a really good book that helped me understand altruism as an example
and where it comes from and just realizing that, you know, the selection is on a level of
genes.
It was a huge insight for me at the time and it sort of, like, cleared up a lot of things
for me.
What do you think about the idea that ideas are the organisms, the meat?
Yes.
Love it.
100%.
Are you able to walk around with that notion for a while that there is an evolutionary kind
of process with ideas as well?
There absolutely is.
There's memes just like genes and they compete and they live in our brains.
It's beautiful.
Are we silly humans thinking that we're the organisms?
Is it possible that the primary organisms are the ideas?
Yeah, I would say like the idea is kind of living in a software of like our civilization
in the minds and so on.
We think as humans that the hardware is the fundamental thing.
I human is a hardware entity, but it could be the software, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I would say like there needs to be some grounding at some point to like a physical
reality.
But if we clone an Andre, the software is a thing like is this thing that makes that
thing special, right?
Yeah.
I guess I, you're right.
But then cloning might be exceptionally difficult.
There might be a deep integration between the software and the hardware in ways we don't
quite understand.
Well, from the ultimate point of view, like what makes me special is more like the gang
of genes that are writing in my chromosomes, I suppose, right?
Like they're they're they're replicating unit, I suppose.
No, but that's just for the cute, the thing that makes you special, sure.
Well, the reality is what makes you special is your ability to survive based on the software
that runs on the hardware that was built by the genes.
So the software is the thing that makes you survive, not the hardware, all right?
It's a little bit of both.
You know, it's just like a second layer, it's a new second layer that hasn't been there
before the brain.
So they both coexist, but there's also layers of the software.
I mean, it's it's not, it's a it's a abstraction at the top of abstractions.
But okay.
So soft is gene and the plane, I would say sometimes books are like not sufficient.
I like to reach for textbooks sometimes.
I kind of feel like books are for too much of a general consumption sometime and they
just kind of like they're too high up in a lot of abstraction and it's not good enough.
So I like textbooks.
I like the cell, I think the cell was pretty cool.
That's why also I like the writing of Nick Lane is because he's pretty willing to step
one level down and he doesn't, yeah, he's willing to go there.
But he's also willing to sort of be throughout the stack.
So he'll go down to a lot of detail, but then he will come back up.
And I think he has a, yeah, basically, I really appreciate that.
That's why I love college, early college, even high school, just textbooks on the basics.
Yeah.
You were science of mathematics, of biology of chemistry, yes, those are, they condense
down like a, it's sufficiently general that you can understand that both the philosophy
and the details, but also like you get homework problems and you get to play with it as much
as you would if you were in programming stuff.
Yeah.
And then I'm also suspicious of textbooks, honestly, because as an example in deep learning,
there's no like amazing textbooks and I feel this changing very quickly.
I imagine the same is true and say synthetic biology and so on.
These books like the cell are kind of outdated.
They're still high level.
Like what is the actual real source of truth?
It's people in wet labs working with cells, you know, sequencing genomes and, yeah, actually
working with, working with it.
And I don't have that much exposure to that or what that looks like.
So I still don't fully, I'm reading through the cell and it's kind of interesting and
I'm learning, but it's still not sufficient, I would say, in terms of understanding what
it's a clean summarization of the mainstream narrative.
Yeah.
But you have to learn that before you break out at the towards the cutting edge.
What is the actual process of working with these cells and growing them and incubating
them and, you know, it's kind of like a massive cooking recipes of making sure your
self-slows and proliferate and then you're sequencing them running experiments and just
how that works.
I think it's kind of like the source of truth of, at the end of the day, what's really
useful in terms of creating therapies and so on.
Yeah.
And the future AI textbooks will be because, you know, there's artificial intelligence
to modern approach.
I actually haven't read if it's come out the recent version, the recent, there's been
a recent addition.
I also saw there's a science of deep learning book.
I'm waiting for textbooks that worth recommending or worth reading.
Yeah.
It's it's tricky because it's like papers and code, code, code.
Honestly, I think papers are quite good.
I especially like the appendix, appendix of any paper as well.
It's like the most detail you can have.
It doesn't have to be cohesive connected to anything else.
You just described me very specific ways of the particular thing.
Yeah.
Many times papers can be actually quite readable, not always, but sometimes the introduction
and the abstract is readable, even for someone outside of the field, not this is not always
true.
And sometimes I think unfortunately scientists use complex terms even when it's not necessary.
I think that's harmful.
I think there's no reason for that.
And papers sometimes are longer than they need to be in the parts that don't matter.
Yeah.
The appendix would be long, but then the paper itself, you know, look at Einstein, make
it simple.
Yeah, but certainly I've come across papers I would say in say like synthetic biology or
something that I thought were quite readable for the abstract and the introduction.
And then you're reading the rest of it and you don't fully understand, but you kind
of are getting a gist and I think it's cool.
What advice, you give advice to folks interested in machine learning and research, but in
general life advice to a young person high school early college about how to have a career
that can be proud of or life they can be proud of.
Yeah, I think I'm very hesitant to give general advice.
I think it's really hard.
I've mentioned like some of the stuff I've mentioned is fairly general.
I think like focus on just the amount of work you're spending on like a thing compared
yourself only to yourself, not to others.
That's good.
I think those are fairly general.
How do you pick the thing?
You just have like a deep interest in something or like try to like find the argmax over like
the things that you're interested in.
Argmax at that moment and stick with it.
How do you not get distracted and switch to another thing?
You can if you like.
Well, if you do an argmax repeatedly every week, it doesn't converge.
It doesn't.
It's a problem.
Yeah, you can like low pass filter yourself in terms of like what has consistently been
true for you.
But yeah, I definitely see how it can be hard, but I would say like you're going to work
the hardest on the thing that you care about the most.
So low pass filter yourself and really introspect in your past, where are the things that gave
you energy and what are the things that took energy away from you, concrete examples.
And usually from those concrete examples, sometimes parents can emerge.
I like it when things look like this when I'm in these positions.
So that's not necessarily the field, but the kind of stuff you're doing in a particular
field.
It seems like you were energized by implementing stuff, building actual things.
Yeah, being low level, learning, and then also communicating so that others can go through
the same realizations and shortening that gap.
Because I usually have to do way too much work to understand a thing.
And then I'm like, okay, this is actually like, okay, I think I get it.
And like, why was it so much work?
It should have been much less work.
And that gives me a lot of frustration and that's why I sometimes go teach.
So aside from the teaching you're doing now, putting out videos, aside from a potential
Godfather Part II, with the AGI at Tesla and beyond, what does the future of Project
Kapati hold?
Have you figured that out yet?
I don't know.
I mean, as you see through the fog of war, that is all of our future.
Do you start seeing silhouettes of what that possible future could look like?
The consistent thing I've been always interested in for me at least is AI and that's probably
why I'm spending my rest of my life on because I just care about it a lot.
And I actually care about like many other problems as well, like say aging, which I basically
view as disease.
And I care about that as well, but I don't think it's a good idea to go after it specifically.
I don't actually think that humans will be able to come up with the answer.
I think the correct thing to do is to ignore those problems and you solve AI and then use
that to solve everything else.
And I think there's a chance that this will work.
I think it's a very high chance.
And that's kind of like the way I'm betting at least.
So when you think about AI, are you interested in all kinds of applications, all kinds of domains,
and any domain you focus on will allow you to get insights to the big problem of AGI?
Yeah.
For me, it's the ultimate meta problem.
I don't want to work on any one specific problem.
There's too many problems.
So how can you work on all problems simultaneously?
You solve the meta problem, which to me is just intelligence.
And how do you automate it?
Is there cool small projects like archive sanity and so on that you're thinking about the
world, the ML world can anticipate?
There's always like some fun side projects.
Yeah.
Archive sanity is one.
Basically, like there's way too many archive papers.
How can I organize it and recommend papers and so on?
I transcribed all of your podcasts.
Yeah.
From that experience, from transcribing the process of like you like consuming audiobooks
and podcasts and so on, here's a process that achieves closer to human level performance
and annotation.
Yeah.
Well, I definitely was like surprised that transcription with opening as Whisperer was
working so well, compared to what I'm familiar with from Siri and like a few other systems,
I guess.
It worked so well and that's what gave me some energy to like try it out.
And I thought it could be fun to run on podcasts.
It's kind of not obvious to me why Whisperer is so much better compared to anything else
because I feel like there should be a lot of incentive for a lot of companies to produce
transcription systems and that they've done so over a long time.
Whisperer is not a super exotic model.
It's a transformer.
It takes male spectrograms and you know, just outputs tokens of text.
It's not crazy.
The model and everything has been around for a long time.
I'm not actually 100% sure why it's not obvious to me either.
It makes me feel like I'm missing something because there's huge, even Google and so on
YouTube transcription.
Yeah.
It's unclear but some of it is also integrating into a bigger system that is so the user interface
how's deployed and all that kind of stuff.
Maybe running it as an independent thing is much easier like an order magnitude easier
than deploying to a large integrated system like YouTube transcription or anything like
meetings.
Zoom has transcription that's kind of crappy but creating interface where the text is
different individual speakers.
It's able to display it in compelling ways, run it real time, all that kind of stuff.
Maybe that's difficult.
I still have the explanation I have because I'm currently paying quite a bit for human
transcription and human caption annotation.
I'm like, it seems like there's a huge incentive to automate that.
Yeah.
It's very confusing.
I mean, I don't know if you looked at some of the whisper transcripts but they're quite
good.
They're good.
And especially in tricky cases, I've seen whisper performance on like super tricky cases
and it doesn't credibly well.
So I don't know.
A podcast is pretty simple.
It's like high quality audio and you're speaking usually pretty clearly.
So I don't know what open AI's plans are either.
But yeah, there's always fun projects basically.
And stable diffusion also is opening up a huge amount of experimentation.
I would say in the visual realm and generating images and videos and movies ultimately.
Yeah, videos now.
And so that's going to be pretty crazy.
That's going to almost certainly work and it's going to be really interesting when the
cost of content creation is going to fall to zero.
You used to need a painter for a few months to paint a thing and now it's going to be
speak to your phone to get your video.
So Hollywood will start using it to generate scenes which completely opens up.
Yeah, so you can make a like a movie like Avatar eventually for under a million dollars.
Much less.
Maybe just by talking to your phone.
I mean, I know it sounds kind of crazy.
And then there'd be some voting mechanism like how do you have a like would there be
a show on Netflix that's generated completely automatically?
And what does it look like also when you can generate it on demand and it's and there's
infinity of it.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
All the synthetic content.
I mean, it's humbling because we treat ourselves as special for being able to generate art
and ideas and all that kind of stuff.
If that can be done in an automated way by AI.
Yeah.
I think it's fascinating to me how these the predictions of AI and what it's going to
look like and what's going to be capable of are completely inverted and wrong.
And sci-fi of 50s and 60s is just like totally not right.
They imagine AI is like super calculating their approvers and we're getting things that
can talk to you about emotions.
They can do art is just like weird.
Are you excited about that feature?
Just AI's like hybrid systems heterogeneous systems of humans and AI's talking about
emotions, Netflix and chill with an AI system that's where the Netflix thing you watch is
also generated by AI.
I think it's going to be interesting for sure.
And I think I'm cautiously optimistic, but it's not obvious.
Well, the sad thing is your brain and mine developed in a time where before Twitter, before
the internet.
So I wonder people that are born inside of it might have a different experience.
Like I and maybe you can still resist it and the people born now will not.
Well, I do feel like humans are extremely malleable.
And you're probably right.
What is the meaning of life, Andre?
We talked about sort of the universe having a conversation with us humans or with the
systems we create to try to answer for the universe, for the creator of the universe
to notice us.
We're trying to create systems that are loud enough to answer back.
I don't know if that's the meaning of life.
That's like meaning of life for some people.
The first level answer I would say is anyone can choose their own meaning of life because
we are conscious entity and it's beautiful.
Number one, but I do think that like a deeper meaning of life is someone is interested
is along the lines of like what the hell is all this and like why?
And if you look at the fundamental physics and the quantum field theory and the standard
model, they're like very complicated and there's this like 19 free parameters of our universe.
And like what's going on with all this stuff and why is it here and can I hack it?
Can I work with it?
Is there a message for me?
Am I supposed to create a message?
And so I think there's some fundamental answers there.
But I think there's actually even like you can't actually like really make dent in those
without more time.
And so to me, also there's a big question around just getting more time, honestly.
Yeah, that's kind of like what I think about quite a bit as well.
So kind of the ultimate or at least first way to sneak up to the why question is to try
to escape the system, the universe.
And then for that, you sort of backtrack and say, okay, for that, it's going to take
a very long time.
So the why question boils down from an engineering perspective to how do we extend?
Yeah, I think that's the question number one, practically speaking because you can't,
you're not going to calculate the answer to the deeper questions in time you have.
And that could be extending your own lifetime or extending just the lifetime of human civilization.
Of whoever wants to, not many people might not want that.
But I think people who do want that, I think, I think it's probably possible.
And I don't think, I don't know that people fully realize this.
I kind of feel like people think of death as an inevitability.
But at the end of the day, this is a physical system.
Somethings go wrong.
It makes sense why things like this happen evolutionarily, speaking.
And there's most certainly interventions that mitigate it.
I mean, that would be interesting if death is eventually looked at as a fascinating thing
that used to happen to humans.
I don't think it's unlikely.
I think it's likely.
And it's up to our imagination to try to predict what the world without death looks
like.
Yes, it's hard to, I think the values will completely change.
It could be.
I don't really buy all these ideas that, oh, without death, there's no meaning, there's
nothingness.
I don't intuitively buy all those arguments.
I think there's plenty of meaning, plenty of things to learn.
They're interesting, exciting.
I want to know, I want to calculate, I want to improve the condition of all the humans
and organisms that are alive.
At the way we find meaning, we change.
There is a lot of humans, probably including myself, that finds meaning in the finiteness
of things.
But that doesn't mean that's the only source of meaning.
Yeah.
I do think many people will go with that, which I think is great.
I love the idea that people can just choose their own adventure.
Like you are born as a conscious, free entity, by default, I'd like to think.
And you have your alienable rights for life in the pursuit of happiness and the nature
of the landscape of happiness.
You can choose your own adventure mostly.
And that's not a fully true, but I'm still pretty sure I'm an NPC, but an NPC can't
know it's an NPC.
There could be different degrees and levels of consciousness.
I don't think there's a more beautiful way to end it.
Andre, you're an incredible person.
I'm really honored you would talk with me.
Everything you've done for the machine learning world, for the AI world, to just inspire
people to educate millions of people.
It's been great.
And I can't wait to see what you do next.
It's been an honor, man.
Thank you so much for talking to me.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Thanks for listening to this conversation with Andre Karpathi.
To support this podcast, please check out our sponsors in the description.
And now let me leave you with some words from Samuel Carlin.
The purpose of models is not to fit the data, but to sharpen the questions.
Thanks for listening and hope to see you next time.